Ihr hört es schon, das kann nur eine Sendung sein, nämlich die, wie hieß die noch gleich? Keine Ahnung.
Strippy.
Dieser vererbte Name, ich weiß nicht, ich mag ja unseren Titel irgendwie nicht.
Welchen?
Mobile Max.
Ja.
War echt.
Vor allem schreiben die noch viele, wenn ich dir so sage, so häh, häh, dann immer MAX natürlich, weil die wissen, dass ich Max bin, dann denken sie, mein Podcast.
Der mobile Max. Tja, was machen wir denn da? Wollen wir uns mal umbenennen? Jetzt, wo der Name so schön eingeführt ist?
Incredible Max.
Mitso und So könnte bald frei werden, oder?
Wieso das?
Wir nennen uns einfach Max und So.
Max und So?
Bitte dich.
Nein, nein, nein.
Steve und So.
Nein, überhaupt nicht und So.
Äpfel und Birnen sind nicht so schlecht.
Ja, das ist schonmal ein interessanter Diskussionsansatz.
Aber bevor wir keine Pizza mehr essen, haben wir immer Bio.
Randtanplan. Rent a plan.
Ja, ist schwierig, ne? Das Problem ist, wir wissen ja eigentlich gar nicht, worum es geht in unserem Podcast.
Warum am Anfang?
Also so eine grobe Ahnung hab ich meistens. Warum am Anfang?
Wieso?
Interessiert jetzt sogar an Scheiß.
Ist jetzt die 51. Sendung, oder? Ist die, ist die.
Kann man auch nach der neuen Namen nachdenken.
Ja, also so verplant wie die letzte, kann es eh nicht werden. Ich bin zwar auch ein bisschen müder, aber ich bin nicht so total mega vollständig komplett müde, wie beim letzten Mal.
Das geht mir ähnlich.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Also Mobile Max finde ich auf jeden Fall auch schon seit eh und je optimierungswürdig.
Aber mir ist ja auch noch nichts besseres eingefallen. Die Geschichte ist ja die, dass das ja mal so ein Blog war und dann ist das alles irgendwie so gekommen. Und dann habe ich beschlossen, aus dem Blog einen Podcast zu machen. Na ja, aber vielleicht ist das ja ein Auftrag für die Hörer. Also angenommen, wir würden uns umbenennen. Ich weiß, dass das nicht funktioniert.
Das ist so wie damals, als Spreeliken Logo gesucht hat über per Massengeschmack. Ich schicke mal was zu.
Das Logo sucht man nicht, die kommen auf einen zu.
Ich fände übrigens das Meta-Ebene-Logo sehr schön.
Oh, das freut mich aber, dass du das sehr schön findest.
Ja, wenn du das gemacht hast, hast du das gut gemacht.
Das war so eine Eingebung.
Ja, sieht man auch.
Genau, wir könnten es ja auch Meta-Max nennen.
Ja, Meta haben wir auf jeden Fall genug.
Meta, oh Meta. Ich glaube, wir haben irgendwie zu viel Kompression hier.
Ja, irgendwie.
Kannst du deine Set-X nicht mal speichern, sag mal?
Immer diese analogen Regeln.
Na, wenn das... Ja, aber du weißt ja, wie das ist.
Jetzt bin ich lauter wieder.
Ja, jetzt sind wir lauter, weil das...
Aber ich glaube, draußen sind wir schon ziemlich laut. Die sagen schon, wir sind ganz schön laut. Und ich bin jetzt auch schon wieder laut.
Ja, ich bin auch unangenehm.
Laut sind wir deshalb, weil ich für...
Und die meinen, wir werden immer lauter.
Wir werden immer lauter werden und wir werden immer lauter werden. Soll ich das jetzt nicht mehr...
Ich glaube, wir kriegen das gerade schon hin mit diesem...
Wir brauchen 200 Flatter pro Stunde sonst. Müssen wir frühzeitig abbrechen.
Können Sie mich noch leiser wieder auf dem...
Ja, ja, ich mach uns jetzt... Ja, alles noch ein bisschen leiser. So, ich kann euch das auch gerne erklären, warum das so ist. Das ist halt immer alles nicht so einfach.
Mit den Knöpchen und den Reglern?
Wir wollen ja eben hier das auch alles ein bisschen weiterzuentwickeln. Und Fortschritt benötigt Änderung. Denn wenn sich nichts ändert, kann auch nichts besser werden. Wir reden hier nicht über Stuttgart, sondern wir reden über...
Berlin Mitte.
Wir reden über... Was ist denn dein... Okay, worüber wollen wir reden? Welchen Fail wollen wir reden?
Ping hatten wir letztes Mal schon. Weetab auch. Da wurden ja in den Kommentaren, wo der ich oder andere, oder wir angefeindet, noch nicht mal so einen Weetab in der Hand gehabt. Aber Hauptsache drüber lästern. Und dann gab es dieses spiegel.de-Video. Dann dachte ich mir ja... Hast du nicht gesehen? spiegel.de hat das Weetab getestet. Und da waren so Kommentare drin wie, ja, so Low-Rest-Videos gehen auch flüssig, High-Rest-Videos zeigen wir nicht, das ist nicht schön.
Der wollte es noch nicht mal zeigen, weil er meinte, das wäre nicht schön.
Das machen wir jetzt gar nicht erst.
Die Chip hat sich ja auch in der Luft zerrissen. Die haben ja gesagt, wenn das in dem Zustand ausgeliefert wird, das darf man einfach nicht so ausliefern. Haben sie aber gemacht Weinbrot.
Ja, ich weiß.
Nee, das ist wirklich traurig. Auch so, wenn sie die Lage erinnern. Hast du das gesehen?
Zehn Sekunden braucht dieses Gerät, um sozusagen eine Rotation mitzukriegen. Dabei klappt es in zwei von drei Fällen nicht. Dabei sieht dieser Bildschirm aus, wie so ein 90er-Jahre X-Windows-Server auf einer unbekannten Grafikkarte, der irgendwie versucht zu starten.
Wahrscheinlich ist es exakt das.
Wahrscheinlich ist es ein X-Windows-Server auf einer Grafikkarte, die man gerade im Bildschirm rumgedreht hat.
Also es ist einfach nichts. Es ist nichts. Dieses VTAP ist einfach nichts. Das ist keine Vision. Das ist noch nichtmal ordentliches Engineering. Das ist reines Marketing. Und meiner Meinung nach ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass diese Firma sich dabei ein PR-Eye Forever legt, sehr hoch. Wahrscheinlich können die schon mal drüber nachdenken, wie sie sich nennen. Weil der Name ist wahrscheinlich...
Das ist eine viel zu kleine Firma, die sich viel zu viel vorgenommen hat.
Ja, und... Ich finde das auch so billig, weißt du? So in diesen iPad-Hype, sich da so einzuklingen und jetzt hier die Herausforderer aus Berlin. Das Silicon Valley Brandenburgs.
Jemand spricht ja jetzt hier heutzutage auch schon von Silicon Coty, hast du gelesen? Am Coty sind jetzt die ganzen Start-ups von Berlin versammelt.
Alle beide.
Das ging letztens übers Twitter, aber da sind tatsächlich einige Internetfirmen, die sich in den ganzen Fabrikhöfen niedergelassen haben, die schön saniert wurden. Und da gibt es jetzt irgendwie so ein kleines Meme, Silicon Coty. Aber Neophonie sitzt ja in Mitte, ne?
Ja, das ist auch glaube ich nicht der richtige breeding ground für sowas. Also ich kenne ja ein paar Leute, die da arbeiten und ich traue so ein bisschen für die.
Aber die distanzieren sich ja alle davon.
Tja, ich meine, was soll man denn davon da noch... Was soll man denn dazu noch sagen?
Aber ich dachte, wir hätten halt wenigstens dann, als sie gemerkt haben, dass es vielleicht auch noch hinten losgeht, noch eine Firma ausgegründet, um so die Verbandlung mit Neophonie zu verhindern.
Ja, die hätten gleich die We-Fail-AG gründen sollen. Da hätten dann irgendwie die ganzen anderen sogenannten Startups ihre ganzen Failures dann auch gleich mitlaunchen können. Dann hätte man schon mal auch so einen German Brand dafür.
Aber wenn wir jetzt darüber schon sprechen, dann müssen wir jetzt ja auch aufs Playbook.
Blackberry ist ja überhaupt jetzt alle mit ihren Taps. Ja, müssen sie.
Aber können sie nicht.
Taps heißt das jetzt.
Chorega-Taps.
Was?
Nein. Playbook heißt das doch, oder?
Ja, das spricht jetzt auf dieses Samsung.
Ach so, dieses Galaxy-Tab.
Also wir sprechen von Slates für die Hörer, die jetzt gerade nicht folgen können.
Also, na gut, ich meine Blackberry, ich meine, die haben schon... Was soll denn das überhaupt? Diese ganzen Ankündigungen. Was versprechen sich diese Firmen davon? Ist Apple der einzige Laden auf diesem Planeten, der es schafft, eine Ankündigung auch mit einer Auslieferung zu verbinden? Ich meine, zumindest meistens, ist es ja auch jetzt nicht so, dass es bei Apple immer so ist.
Weißes iPhone sag ich noch.
Weißes iPhone, ja, oder hier 27 Zoll-Bildschirm und so. Ich meine, kann ja sein, dass mal was dazwischenkommt. Das ist nicht das, was ich meine. Aber teilweise sind ja Sachen angekündigt worden, die dann einfach nie das Licht der Welt erblickt hat. Und nirgendswo scheint diese Fail-Quote so hoch zu sein, wie bei diesem Tablet-Ding. Das fing irgendwie an mit diesem Cramp-Pad, genau. Das ging voll leiden los und vor allem auch immer so richtig mit so Soap-Opera-Dram. Das sich dann alle zerstreiten und hassen und verklagen und bevor auch nur einer rumgeklickt hat. Und dann irgendwann Monate nachdem der Hype irgendwie da drum weg ist. Für dieses Cramp-Pad haben sie ja sogar einen Preis, so ein Product of the Year oder so ein Scheiß bekommen. Für ein Produkt, das es gar nicht gibt, ja. Nur für so eine blöde Idee, die in so einem Blog formuliert wurde. Und dann kommt dieses Teil dann wirklich irgendwann mal raus und dann ist es immer dieses Elend, ja. Akku hält nicht, dreht nicht, Touch funktioniert nicht und dann immer so, ja, das nächste Software-Update und so wird das fixen.
Ich glaube, das ist sowas, was diese Tablets seit Jahren eigentlich bekannt, was jeder haben möchte. Nämlich, du möchtest gerne irgendwas in der Hand halten, was du mit dem Finger bedienen kannst, was jetzt eine relativ simple Idee ist. Spätestens durchs iPhone ist das dann richtig fett befeuert worden und dann trauen sie wahrscheinlich auch so, naja, so schwer kann es ja nicht sein. Kleine Prozessoren gibt es lang genug, ein kleines Display und dann packen wir da Linux drauf und alles ist Dufte. Und dann probiert man es halt mal und dann musste natürlich auch, wenn Du entsprechend klein bist und nicht die finanziellen Hintergründe hast und so, musst Du entsprechend auch Dampf machen und ein bisschen Bekanntheitsgrad dafür sorgen, ein bisschen die Werbetrommel drehen und dann stehst Du irgendwann so da und hast kein vernünftiges Produkt hergestellt, weil Du dich halt doch immer noch hast. Und bei Blackberry, ich glaube, die haben Angst davor, dass ihnen ihr Aktienkurs wegbricht.
Na ja gut, ich meine, RIM ist ja nun wirklich eine der wenigen Firmen, denen es derzeit noch nicht schlecht geht. Also ich meine, die sehen wahrscheinlich schon, dass Apple für sie langfristig eine enorme Konkurrenz darstellt, auch in ihrem Business-Segment. Aber in den letzten Jahren gehörten sie ja zu denen, die noch mit wachsendem Marktanteil überhaupt gesegnet sind. Also RIM und Apple sind ja beide gestiegen, weil sie die Einzigen waren, die einfach schon eine etablierte Marke im Smartphone-Bereich hatte. Und die hatten vor allem beide eine klare Zielgruppe. Apple die Konsumer, RIM die Business-Welt. Und deswegen sind die beiden stark, und deswegen sind die anderen einfach alle nicht stark, weil sie nämlich weder das eine noch das andere in irgendeiner Form richtig...
Ja, aber ich glaube, dass RIM, die haben auch kein vernünftiges Betriebssystem mehr so richtig.
Da wird es aber jetzt interessant.
Genau, die haben QNX dafür gekauft.
Und das ist, wer das nicht kennt, also QNX ist ein ganz alter Hase und das war...
Echtzeitbetriebssystem, so ein embedded Echtzeitbetrieb.
Genau, das sind die ersten, die eigentlich Nennenswerte, die eigentlich von Anfang an schon immer genau das propagiert haben, was heute einfach der heiße Scheiß ist. Nämlich klein, mit geringen Speicheranforderungen, multiprocessingfähig, multi-core-tauglich mit irgendwie Threads. Das heißt, QNX ist wirklich ein Betriebssystem, wo das nicht alles oben draufgesetzt ist, sondern die vom Start weg schon immer genau diese Fähigkeiten im Vordergrund haben.
Die haben einen dieser Maßrohbe angetrieben.
Jaja, das ist so ein richtiges Hardcore...
Bist du sicher?
Ich weiß das daher, weil...
Nee, du meinst... Ich weiß nicht, ob sie da auch sind. Also es gibt ein anderes, das nenne ich gerade jetzt nicht. Wie heißt denn nochmal das andere Teil? Es gibt noch so ein anderes Ding. Ich würde es aber auch nicht ausschließen, dass QNX auch im Space ist. Ich weiß es aber nicht.
Also auf der QNX-Seite in Wikipedia steht jedenfalls nichts zum Mars Rover.
Wie hieß denn nochmal dieses andere Embedded Betriebssystem, was Mars zum Einsatz...
Verwechsel ich das jetzt gerade?
Das kann gut sein. Aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht so richtig, was dagegen sprechen würde.
Ist auf jeden Fall hier in...
Also ich würde mal sagen, es ist gut abgehangen. Mir ist aber jetzt unklar, was QNX in den letzten Jahren gemacht hat. Denn... Genau, VXWorks.
Ich hab dich geirrt.
Genau, VXWorks. Weil die große Frage ist ja, kann man jetzt sozusagen auch das entsprechende User Interface bringen? Und Multitouch und so weiter. Meine Micro-Körner, das ist alles wichtig. Multiprozessing, klein sein, geringen Speicherbedarf haben, das ist alles in Ordnung. Aber es geht halt um dieses User Interface. Wo dieses VTab wahrscheinlich komplett fehlen wird. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass die das noch auf die Reihe kriegen. Und dass diese ganzen Software-Updates, von denen sie jetzt reden, die sie noch bringen wollen, die werden einfach nicht kommen. Zumindest nicht in befriedigendem Maße.
Die werden schon Updates bringen, das ist ja noch nicht so schwer. Die werden das schon noch ein bisschen verbessern. Aber mit Apple hat man natürlich einen riesigen Konkurrenten.
Aber wenn sie das Gerät ein bisschen verbessern, dann ist da noch überhaupt nichts gewonnen.
Die müssen Apple jetzt auch nicht toppen. Das schaffen die eh nicht, mal ganz ehrlich. Aber da kann man ja trotzdem ein Produkt verkaufen.
Ja, die haben keine Chance.
Aber an wem?
Wer soll denen das kaufen?
Allen, denen irgendwie die Apple-Hasser dies gibt, da gibt es dann auf jeden Fall genug von.
Ja, aber dann kaufen wir jetzt ein Android-Gerät.
Apple-Hater.
Das ist doch egal.
Wir sind ja im Mobile-Max und nicht im Mobile-Gpad. Also ich denke, die werden da schon noch ein bisschen was machen.
Also ich glaube, was ein deutlicher Hinweis ist auf die Zukunft von dem VTab, ist, dass sie am Anfang damit geworben haben, dass sie diese ganzen Verlage mit an Bord bringen und dass sie von allen da, von der Morgenpost und weiss ja was, immer schön die Apps drauf haben und die das ja alle toll finden wie sonst was und dass sie jetzt nicht einen Verlag mit an Bord haben beim Start. Also selbst die Verlage. Ich weiß natürlich jetzt nicht, vielleicht kommt ja auch noch irgendwas mal, aber selbst die Verlage, die man glaube ich tendenziell so was noch relativ leicht andrehen kann, sind jetzt zu dem Punkt gekommen, so neeeeh.
Das ist auch jetzt ein interessanter Punkt, über den ich ein bisschen nachgedacht habe. Weißt du was ich nämlich glaube? Diese Neophonie ist wahrscheinlich ein gutes Beispiel dafür, dass diese Firmen nicht verstehen, wer eigentlich ihre Kunden sind. Da gab es doch dieses schöne Zitat, was Steve Jobs wieder in den Mund gelegt wird, dass er das die Musikfirmen mal gefragt hat. Wer sind denn eure Kunden? Und die Antwort war, naja Walmart. Weil die sozusagen ihnen die CDs abkaufen, die sie dann anderen Leuten verkaufen. Und das ist sozusagen die Denke, die da ist. Deswegen ist der ganze Markt auch so bekloppt. Ich meine, stell dir mal vor, Apple würde sagen, ihre Kunden seien die Computer-Läden.
Ihre eigenen?
Na ja, dass sie das nicht tun, denke ich, das ist offensichtlich. Aber man stellt sich mal vor, das würden sie machen. Ja, ihre Kunden wären Karstadt oder so.
Na ja, so wie Sony Ericsson oder Nokia halt sagen, unsere Kunden sind Vodafone und T-Mobile und Konsort. Genau.
Und genau deswegen kommt da auch so ein Crap bei raus. Und in diesem Neophonie, also ich hab da jetzt nicht wirklich Deep Inside, was die jetzt wirklich getan haben, aber gerade dieses ganze Gerede von den Verlagen und diesen Ups für Lesen und so weiter, diese merkwürdige Magazin-Begeisterung, die da derzeit ist mit diesem ganzen E-Book und Spiegel abklimm bimm. Ich glaube, dass das lange trägt. Lass mich das noch kurz anbringen. Also ich glaube, dass sich da eben auch teilweise so eine Denke manifestiert, so wie, meine Neophonie ist eine Firma, deren Kunden ist der Mittelstand.
Die haben auch viele Verlager als Kunden. Die haben tatsächlich viele von diesen Labs auch entwickelt.
Das sind nämlich ihre Kunden. Ihre Kunden sind nämlich Verlage. Und deswegen haben sie ein Produkt gemacht für Verlage, also von dem sie glauben, dass die Verlage darauf aufspringen würden. Aber am Ende ist es halt nicht der Verlag, der vor diesem Gerät sitzt und klickt, sondern es ist halt potenziell irgendein Nutzer. Und den gibt es einfach nicht. Und für den ist es auch nicht entwickelt.
Aber sagen wir so, wenn du einen Verlag findest, der bereit ist, das quasi zu subventionieren und deinen Kunden oder dem Endanwender zu einem abstrus subventionierten Preis aufs Auge drückt, in der Hoffnung, damit irgendwann mal ein Geschäftsmodell aufbauen zu können, dann kann die als Hersteller ja im Endeffekt, zumindest kurzfristig gesehen, wurscht sein, ob das irgendjemand benutzt oder nicht, solange du irgendeinen Verlag überzeugen kannst, hier kaufen wir davon mal 500.000 Stück ab.
Ja, aber die Verlage kaufen diese Geräte nicht.
Offensichtlich nicht selbst. Die sind nicht doof genug dafür.
Warum sollste das auch machen?
Ach, naja, ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass du die...
Und dann legen sie das der Zeitung bei oder was? Ja, ist doch bekloppt.
Ja, klar ist das bekloppt. Aber ich meine, ich glaube, die Verlage haben Angst vor Google, mit anderen Worten, sie wollen nicht so richtig auf Android wahrscheinlich, sie haben Angst vor Apple, deswegen wollen sie nicht auf iOS. Die haben Angst vor Amazon, also nehmen sie halt irgendein crappyes, selbstentwickeltes OS und reden sich da schön, weil da brauchen sie erst mal, da brauchen sie vor, niemand Angst zu haben und können in aller Ruhe sich selber in den Arsch treten.
Aber was da halt dann irgendwie fehlt, finde ich ja, also ich meine, wenn du jetzt irgendwie sagst, okay, ich will jetzt mal hier Apps entwickeln und so...
Ich finde das Gerät nicht gut, um Himmels willen. Ich möchte jetzt da nichts schönreden. Ich kann mir nur vorstellen, wie man auf die Idee kommen könnte, dass man damit eine realistische Chance hätte. Und auch diese Denk-Wir-Wir unterstützen anders. Wir unterstützen R und wir unterstützen Android und du kannst eine tiefe Linux-Programme drauf.
Aber jetzt verfolgen wir das nochmal weiter. Also immer diese Frage, wer ist denn eigentlich unser Kunde? Und wenn man jetzt schaut, dass Blackberry, also RIM, ein Blackberry-Produkt anpreist, was ja hier unsere Visionen usw. bekanntgegeben, das heißt Playbook.
Playbook? Von RIM.
Was meinen Sie bitte damit? Ich meine, Ihre Kunden sind Business-Leute. Wollen die ein Spielbuch haben?
Nein, da übersetzt du gerade Playbook falsch. Playbook ist das Manuskript, also das Drehbuch quasi. Also das, was du auch... Also Play by the Book ist glaube ich auch so eine Redewendung, für das es perfekt gelaufen.
Wir wollen jetzt auch nicht ein Produkt in einem Namen schlecht machen, oder?
Nee, ich frage mich halt nur jetzt in dem Kontext, was ist Rhyms Vision, was ihre Kunden sind? Wollen sie jetzt auch in Apples Turf, wollen sie auf den Massenmarkt, wollen sie den Konsumermarkt, oder bauen sie ein Tablett für ihre Kernzielgruppe?
Das ist für die Kernzielgruppe. Das ist also angekündigt halt das quasi das Profi Tablett. Damit kann man natürlich auch alles machen, was so Spaß macht. Naja, nicht Profi, ich weiß nicht wie es ist. Ich hab mir den Spot angeguckt, und da ging die Enterprise Tablett, glaube ich. Und die werden da halt so Video-Conferencing, das werden sie groß machen, und damit wird man tolle Präsentationen halten sollen. Und damit kann man natürlich seine Mails machen, wie man von einem Blackberry gewohnt ist. Und auch noch ein bisschen Twitter und Konsorten, weil klar, braucht man ja heutzutage, alles ist ja auch Business-Business wichtig.
Den traue ich ja noch am meisten zu, dass die das auf die Reihe kriegen.
Weil die sind halt auch so ihr Closed-Ecosystem, die machen halt nur so ihr eigenes Zeug, sind jetzt nicht so irgendwie, ja unser OS läuft auf allen oder...
Eigene Hardware, eigene Software, die haben sich auch extra eine Software eingekauft, also die sind da schon auf jeden Fall...
Und sie haben halt irgendwie schon dicken Batzen Kunden, die drauf stehen, also kann man nicht leugnen.
Sie schmeißen ihr Betriebssystem vielleicht gerade noch so rechtzeitig weg. Weil ich weiß nicht, was für eine Zukunft das Original BlackBerry OS noch hat. Weil das macht mir nicht so den Eindruck, als ob es so super für Touch geeignet wäre oder als ob es ein modernes Betriebssystem wäre. Und dann lieber rechtzeitig noch die Reißleine ziehen, als so wie Microsoft zu warten, bis das Pferd anfängt zu stinken, weil es so tot ist.
Und rechtzeitig die Reißleine ziehen, drei Jahre nach der Einführung des iPhones.
Ja, aber bisher geht es... Du sagst ja selber, bisher geht es Ihnen noch gut. Also bisher...
Ihnen geht es noch gut mit dem alten Produkt.
Genau, Ihnen geht es noch gut mit dem neuen Produkt. Nicht erst warten, bis der Markt wieder einbricht, um dann festzustellen, wir brauchen vielleicht mal ein langes neues OS haben und dann lieber quasi am Höhepunkt zu sagen und jetzt schon darauf vorbereiten, dass das auch so weitergeht.
Von der Developer-Strategie habe ich nichts gehört, dass Sie jetzt sagen, wir steigen um auf QNX und das ist unser neues Betriebssystem. Sie haben nur gesagt, wir werden irgendwann vielleicht mal im Frühjahr ein Tablett rausbringen, was wir euch jetzt nicht zeigen können, aber wir haben ja ein paar schöne Animationen gemacht.
Von Apple hört man aber auch immer nie was, die sind doch sehr geheim und horisch und die sind vielleicht jetzt auch so. Nichts verraten vorher, sondern...
Ja gut, aber wenn Sie die Entscheidung gemacht haben, dann kommunizieren Sie die auch klar. Apple sagt nicht...
Ja, die sagen vorher nichts die ganze Zeit und dann gibt es halt ein Event und hier ist das Produkt, so sieht es aus, so viel kostet es und gibt es alles.
Und hier ist die WWDC und so, das ist jetzt die Marschroute und das ist unser neues Betriebssystem, na klar.
Aber damals bei Mac OS X, da haben Sie, also da haben Sie, als das noch nicht auf dem Markt war, haben Sie es schon angekündigt, Sie haben gesagt, wir werden es machen, Sie haben die Entwickler langsam mit an die Hand genommen.
Das war ja eine Notsituation.
Ja, aber das ist doch ein langsamer Übergang.
Ja gut, aber Sie haben es klar gesagt, aber RIM hat es nicht klar gesagt, RIM hat gesagt, ach ja, übrigens, hier ist unser neues Produkt, was es noch nicht gibt und das hat ein neues Betriebssystem.
Ja, und dann haben Sie gesagt, Sie haben gesagt, dass man damit mit Java entwickeln können wird. Und mit Flash. Mit Flash, genau. Das habe ich schon mal gehört. Es gibt Nativ und man kann alte Blackberry-Applikationen und so weiter machen.
Geile Strategie. Ich würde sagen, RIM ist total doomed. Also die sind jetzt auch mal wirklich auf meiner Abrufliste gelandet. Und ich sagte ja auch, warum. Den selben Scheiß habe ich vor drei Jahren von Nokia gehört. Das hatten wir ja glaube ich schon ein paar Mal.
Wir fangen heute mit dem Bashing an und hören dann mit den Lobreisungen.
Nokia muss jetzt auf jeden Fall noch mal eins aufs Maul kriegen. Weil das ist einfach mal, die sind...
Bleibt mal bei RIM.
Das ist doch ein schönes Blau, das sie machen.
Aber es ist halt genau das, was Nokia vor ein paar Jahren auch erzählt hat. Aber wir sind doch offen für alle Developer. Du kannst Flash machen. Du kannst Java machen. Du kannst JavaScript machen. Du kannst Native machen. Du kannst Qt machen. Ich war auf dieser Session. Sie haben acht APIs aufgezählt. Und sie waren ernsthaft der Meinung, das wäre jetzt ein echter Grund, auf diese Plattform zu gehen. Ich meine, das bedeutet doch nur, dass sie sich um keine richtig kümmern. Die meisten davon noch nicht mal selber unter Kontrolle haben. Und überhaupt nicht klar ist, welche dieser Plattformen was kann. Das heißt, du weißt überhaupt nicht, in was du irgendwie was entwickeln kannst, wo du eben die größten Chancen hast. Und das ist ein echtes Problem heutzutage. Das kann man sich nicht mehr leisten. Da finde ich Palm, wie heißen sie jetzt? Oder heißt das noch Palm?
Ich weiß das gar nicht.
Also das WebOS. Abgesehen davon, dass es eine unfassbare Abwesenheit von konkreten Ankündigungen gibt, was denn da jetzt eigentlich draus werden soll. Wird es überhaupt noch Telefone geben oder wird das jetzt nur noch ein TabletOS sein? Und wann kommt dieses Tablet?
Erst mal wird WebOS 2.0 ja zunächst kommen. Und dann wird auch über kurz oder lang das Tablet kommen.
Aber erst mal das neue OS.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass da was kommt. Aber zumindest war, als sie das rausgebracht haben, die Aussage erst mal ganz klar, wir setzen hier auf JavaScript. Ich denke zwar, dass das zu wenig war. Sie haben das ja auch selber korrigieren müssen, indem sie dann sagen, wenn ihr Spiele machen wollt, dann gibt es halt irgendwie auch noch nativ irgendwas. Es ist halt alles ein bisschen schwierig mit dem hybriden Ansatz. Aber im Prinzip ist das bei Apple ja auch nicht anders. Es gibt da zwei Development Environments.
Die sich aber sehr ähneln.
Coco und Carmen, oder wovon sprecht ihr jetzt? Was?
Coco und JavaScript? Ja, ich rede von iOS. Im Vergleich zu WebOS.
Okay, machen wir weiter.
Das kann man nicht häufig genug betonen. Es gibt zwei Entwicklungsumgebungen. Die eine kann halt alles und das ist halt Objective-C und Coco und das andere ist halt The Web. Und bei Palm ist es so, dass sie eben auch auf The Web setzen, aber dass sie das eben auch als ihr primäres Systemframework verstanden haben wollen und das ja so propagiert haben. Und das halte ich an sich auch für einen konsequenten Ansatz. Später sind sie dann aber halt hingekommen und gesagt, okay, jetzt gibt es hier auch noch was Natives, wo du irgendwie mit C rangehen kannst, damit du auch performante Spiele programmieren kannst. Weil das ist halt einfach in diesen JavaScript-Environments heute so noch nicht vorstellbar. Es ist durchaus denkbar, dass sich das technologisch noch mal so weit entwickelt, dass das keinen großen Unterschied mehr macht. Aber das ist derzeit einfach nicht so. Das hat Apple im Prinzip richtig verstanden. Und zwar deshalb, weil sie das halt einfach wissen, weil sie seit über 20 Jahren Betriebssystementwicklung machen und Erkenntnisse haben.
Mir fällt gerade so ein, dass es ja am Anfang einfach auch keine Developer Apps gibt. Das ist schon ganz schön lange her jetzt auch wieder.
Was bei iOS.
Ja, dass man da auch nur so, dass er da auch nur am Anfang mit dieser Ansage kam, irgendwie, ja, hier so, wenn ihr selber Apps machen wollt, da gab es einfach nur die von Apple mitgelieferten Apps.
Könnte Web-Apps machen, hier so SIDGETS konnte man machen eigentlich.
Zu mehr wollten sie sich halt zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht kommenten.
Wollte ich heute gar nicht mehr vorstellen.
Denn uns dort nicht mal voraus, also noch nicht mal angekündigt, ne? Die haben erst mal gar nichts gesagt.
Ja, angekündigt ja sowieso.
Weil sie halt nur dann was ankündigen, wenn sie auch was liefern können. Und zu dem Zeitpunkt haben sie wahrscheinlich da drüber einfach noch kräftig nachgedacht, wie muss überhaupt ein API aussehen, was halt Touch macht? Und die einzigen Prototypen waren halt die Applikationen auf ihrem Programm. Die ganze 1.0-Apps haben natürlich schon dieses Coco Touch API benutzt. Es ist ja nicht so, dass sie das dann erst aus dem Hut rausgezogen haben. Sie haben halt nur gesagt, ihr dürft das erst mal noch nicht benutzen, weil wir uns selber einfach noch überhaupt nicht sicher sind, ob wir hier das richtige Design gewählt haben. Und dann haben sie nach einem halben Jahr drüber nachgedacht und dann haben sie gesagt, okay, alles klar, das geht in die richtige Richtung. Wir müssen wahrscheinlich da und da und da und da noch Änderungen machen. Dann haben sie das angekündigt und dann haben sie es ein halbes Jahr später auch gebracht. Und seitdem geht es ja auch munter vorwärts. Also ich finde, das macht alles irgendwie Hand und Fuß. Und was die anderen machen, das ist halt einfach ohne Hand und Fuß. Und vor allem dieses, ich verstehe einfach nicht, wie kann man so ignorant sein gegenüber so etwas Fundamentalem, wie das Betriebssystem, auf dem alles läuft? Also Nokia hat jetzt in den letzten Jahren, ich weiß nicht, wie viele Namen durch den Raum gejagt, mit verschiedenen APIs, jetzt sind sie bei Migu gelandet. Migu ist dann wiederum die Melange und ihrem letzten Ansatz mit dem, was Intel macht. Intel. Warum Intel?
Weil Intel genauso verzweifelt ist.
Ja, genau, das ist der Club, der verzweifelt. Das ist wirklich diese Nokia-Abteilung. Und das Schlimmste ist, die merken das noch nicht. Ich bin wieder überrascht, die ganzen Nokia-Mitarbeiter hier, die haben alle, weiß ich nicht, sehr lange gebraucht, bis sie irgendwie angefangen haben, langsam Angst um ihren Job zu entwickeln. Ja, das war's. Naja, also, ich weiß nicht, wenn ich da arbeiten würde, ich würde mir einen neuen Job suchen.
Jungs, ich arbeite da nicht.
Ich auch. Ja, bloß aber bei Nokia fehlt immer noch die Vision. Ich meine, das ist einfach total unklar. Sie haben jetzt drei Betriebssysteme im Rennen.
Drei Stück.
Sie haben jetzt erstmal einen neuen CEO gekriegt.
Oh ja, von Microsoft. Das Gerücht. Ich meine, was wäre, wenn Microsoft Nokia kauft? Ich glaube, so bescheuert ist nicht mal Microsoft. Naja, also, aus der Logik von Microsoft heraus, Nokia hat alles das...
Wir haben Handybetriebssystem und jetzt brauchen wir neue Handys dazu oder was?
Nokia hat alles das, was Microsoft nicht hat, aber gerne hätte.
Ein schlechtes Betriebssystem?
Eine ordentliche Hardware-Entwicklung. Das kann man Nokia nicht vorwerfen, dass sie nicht in der Lage sind, Geräte zu bauen. Das können sie. Sie bauen solide, stabile Geräte, die weltweit in dreifacher Millionen Stückzahl jährlich rausgehauen werden und die irgendwie ja funktionieren.
Über ein Nebtelefon kann man auch so oft drüber fahren mit dem Auto wie über ein iPhone.
War es nicht eine Aussage von Steve, dass er gesagt hat, die Hardware ist jetzt bei den Mobiltelefonen nicht mehr so wichtig wie die Software, das ändert sich gerade und deswegen steigt er halt da ein, weil die Software viel wichtiger wird und die Hardware, die kaufen wir uns irgendwie ein. Und Nokia hat halt nur noch die Hardware, aber die haben sich halt nicht um die Software gekümmert.
Wenn du dir das iPhone anschaust, dann kann man ja nicht sagen, dass die Hardware unwichtig ist.
Aber die machen die nicht selbst, nicht so richtig.
Wer macht die nicht selbst?
Sie haben alles zusammen gekauft und ein bisschen in Finion hier, ein bisschen Samsung da und alles irgendwie zusammengeschustert.
Das war schon immer so.
Ja, bei Nokia ist es nicht so.
Die Chips werden sich auch einkaufen.
Also erstens der Prozessor wird mittlerweile auch von Apple designed. Der A4. Na ja, nur der Prozessor, wo das gesamte System drin ist. Mich würd's noch nicht mal wundern, wenn sie irgendwann noch mal anfangen, Baseband-Chips zu entwickeln.
Und design ist jetzt auch ein bisschen übertrieben. Die nehmen den Armchor und kleben da ein bisschen Module hier und ein bisschen da dran.
Ja, bei Nokia macht das doch jetzt auch nicht anders.
Also das ist jetzt nicht so, dass du mal eben mal was sagst.
Aber bei Nokia, die kümmern sich glaube ich schon noch ein bisschen mehr um Hardware. Was ist eben der Fehler? Sie hat sich mehr um die Software kümmern müssen. Also jetzt hat man ein bisschen rüber shift müssen.
Genau, weil sie sind nämlich eine Hardware Driven-Company. Aber lassen wir mal kurz bei diesen Microsoft-Gedanken bleiben. Ich sag nicht, dass sie das tun werden und ich sag auch nicht, dass sie das tun sollten. Obwohl ich mich in gewisser Hinsicht, ich weiß nicht, ich muss jetzt den Gedanken selber erstmal zu Ende führen. Also Nokia hat das, was Microsoft nicht hat. Sie können irgendwie Hardware produzieren. Sie haben den asiatischen, indischen Markt weitgehend bestückt. Die einzige große Schwäche, die sie haben, ist Nordamerika. Da ist Microsoft wiederum vergleichsweise stark. Wenn jetzt auch nicht so sehr im Telefon- und Hardware-Bereich an sich, aber sie sind sozusagen präsent. In dem Moment, wo Microsoft Nokia gehört, wäre die Aussage, dass Nokia-Telefone oder Microsoft- oder Zoom-Telefone, wie sie dann vielleicht heißen, released werden. Genau, mit Windows Phone 7. Dann würden alle so aufhorchen und sagen, oh, oh, oh, oh. Ich hätte keine besonderen Erwartungen daran, aber es würde irgendwie ein Stück weit fragen.
Aber genau das würden alle tun. Es würden alle aufhorchen und sagen, oh, oh, oh. HTC würde nämlich sagen, oh, oh, jetzt haben die eine eigene Hardware-Produktion. Jetzt sind sie plötzlich nicht mehr Betriebssystem-Lieferant, sondern jetzt sind sie Konkurrenz von uns. Mit anderen Worten, alle Features, alles was neu ist, würde dieses MS-Nokia-Telefon vorher kriegen. Genau das Gleiche würde sich Samsung denken. Microsoft würde sich das Geschäftsmodell von wegen wir produzieren die Software und ihr kümmert euch um die billige Hardware, mit dem sie am PC-Markt groß geworden sind, mit dem sie im Mobiltelefon-Markt sicherlich auch nicht so extrem schlecht verdient haben.
Doch, die haben da extrem schlecht mit verdient. Die haben nämlich überhaupt gar nichts verdient.
Haben die bei Windows Mobile draufgezahlt die ganzen Jahre? Ich weiß es nicht.
Das ist alles der einzige Fail.
Ja, aber die werden Nokia nicht kaufen. Also Nokia ist viel zu fett, Nokia hält sich für viel zu wert.
Ja, aber Microsoft hat zumindest das, was Nokia nicht hat.
Viele haben das, was Nokia nicht haben.
Ja, aber wo soll Nokia das kriegen? Keiner wird es ja Nokia geben.
Dann müsste Nokia Microsoft kaufen.
Sie könnten Android nehmen.
Ja, das werden sie nicht tun.
Das werden sie nicht tun, weil dann sind sie völlig von der Rolle. Wobei, ich würde das noch nicht mal ausschließen.
Das haben sie selber ausgeschrieben.
Die glauben derzeit noch daran, dass sie eine eigene Softwarestrategie losgetreten bekommen und ich glaube, sie werden das nicht schaffen.
Also Nokia hat gesagt, wenn sie jetzt auf Android setzen würden, das wäre wie sich in die eigenen Schuhe pissen, weil man warme Füße haben möchte. Das ist ein Zitat. Also ich glaube nicht, dass sie Androids einsetzen werden in nächster Zeit.
Ja gut, aber was ist für sie die Alternative?
Und ich meine, das finden die, die wissen viel über den Winter.
Die Alternative ist, dass sie es schaffen, ein eigenes Betriebssystem loszutreten.
Klar, das ist jetzt so die...
Ja, aber seit mehreren Jahren laufen sie rum wie Linder.
Ja, das heißt aber nicht, dass alles vergebend ist. Ich meine, wir haben Apple gesehen, wie die Ende der 90er-Jahre, Anfang des Jahrtausends, rumgehampelt haben. Denen hätte man jetzt auch keine extrem große Chance mehr gegeben, als da alle drei Minuten der Performer 475, 476, 477 rauskam. Und so, das ist... Ich meine, so eine Firma kann sich theoretisch auch wandeln. Nun ist das bei so einem Monster wie Nokia so ein Riesenschiff...
Apple hatte aber damals schon etwas, was Nokia heute nicht hat. Loyale Kunden.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die noch so loyal waren.
Die Leute, die Nokia wählen, sind Nokia scheißegal.
Das ist Helsinki-Syndrom. Nee, Stockholm-Syndrom. Wenn du nämlich so viel Geld bezahlt, bist du ja so eine Art Geise. Und dann willst du natürlich, dass es auch irgendwie sich gelohnt hat.
Jetzt bist du wieder bei diesem Hate-Boy. Du bist ein Hate-Boy.
Hate-Boy?
Hate-Boy.
Ja, ich dachte, man muss mal was gegen dieses Fanboy-Ding machen. Ja, das kann ja auch sein, aber dann sind die Leute halt loyal. Aber das ist bei Nokia halt nicht der Fall.
War ich, ganz lange. Ich hab mal ein 6310i gehabt, bis ich...
Ach, du meinst, bei Nokia haben die Leute viel Geld bezahlt?
Du hast ja gesagt, dass Apple loyale Kunden hat.
Ja gut, aber die hatten nicht loyale...
Hab ich nur einen Grund für gegeben.
Ja, okay, gut. Ich würde sagen, es gab andere Gründe. Also das war bei manchen auch so gewesen sein.
Also bei Apple war damals auch nicht nur alles gut.
Nein, ich sag nicht, dass alles gut war, aber Apple war der einzige Ort, wo dieses Versprechen im Raum klebte, dass man eigentlich die tollsten Geräte haben will. Dass das ein paar Jahre nicht funktioniert hat, ist ja auch anders.
Aber ich kenn auch sehr, sehr, sehr loyale Nokia, wie heißt das, N900, N800?
Diese Terminal-Freaks. Die kaufen sich dieses Telefon, weil SSH draufläuft. Das ist ihre Killer-Applikation.
Ja klar, wovon hat Apple jahrelang gelebt? Von Leuten, die die Term... Außer von allem, außer SSH.
Das N900 ist nur bei Meganerds, die da halt in der Lage sind, ihr komplexes VPN-SSH-Setup zu machen, um dann ganz nach einem Text-Chat rumzuhängen. Aber das ist kein Markt mit dem Nokia 100 Millionen...
Aber das sind loyale Kunden, Menschenskinder.
Apple hat da auch ganz wenig.
Ja, aber 20. Ja, das ist vielleicht der Kundenstamm, über den ich neophil von wie freuen würde, wenn sie den dazu gewöhnen würden.
Es gab Zeiten, da hätte sich Apple über so einen Kundenstamm auch gefreut. Also ich finde, ich sehe jetzt nichts kommen. Aber Nokia ist eine unglaublich große Firma. Da rennen potenziell unglaublich viele talentierte Leute rum. Oder nicht unglaublich viele, aber da rennen ein paar talentierte Leute rum. Und es gibt da durchaus einige, die sicherlich was Gutes aus dem Boden stampfen könnten. Sicherlich nichts Revolutionäres, aber was Gutes, wenn man sie nur lassen würde. Und ich glaube, was Nokia einfach, was da halt das ganz große Problem ist, ist, wie bei jeder größeren Firma, dass die wahrscheinlich eine absurde Bürokratie haben. Da gab es ja auch so einige Interviews, wo man natürlich auch sagen kann, ja, das sind enttäuschte ehemalige Mitarbeiter, aber die so angedeutet haben, ja, wir hatten eine Abteilung, die neue Betriebssystemdesigns vorgelegt haben und wir haben da 500 Verbesserungsvorschläge vorgelegt in den letzten 20 Jahren. Davon ist nicht einer durchgekommen. Das war wirklich so die Aussage, 500 in den letzten zehn Jahren und nicht einer davon durchgenommen. Und wenn man das ein bisschen ausmistet, dann könnte da durchaus eventuell nochmal was kommen. Das heißt jetzt nicht, dass ich fest damit rechne, aber ja.
Was für ein Ausblick für ein Weltkonzern. Vielleicht, wenn man endlich mal unter Umständen jemanden zuhört, dann könnte unter Umständen vielleicht...
Das ist der Ausblick von jedem Weltkonzern, dem der Markt unter den Füßen wegbricht. Das wird Mercedes-Benz nicht anders gehen, wenn Elektro-Ortos mal richtig kommen. Das glaube ich tatsächlich. Wenn du eine gewisse Größe erreicht hast, dann...
Ich glaube, dass Nokia irgendwann die Basis schwinden wird. Weil mit diesen Margen im Feature-Phone-Bereich werden sie einfach nicht überleben können. Sie müssen die neuen Märkte auch mitnehmen. Und derzeit verlieren sie diese Märkte nur.
Ohne Frage.
Sie sind zwar jetzt rein von ihrem Unit-Market-Share in dem Smartphone-Bereich noch irgendwie mit dabei. Aber das sind auch alles die Smartphones, die eben gerade so eben Smartphones sind. Das heißt, sie sind nicht im Ansatz in dem Preisbereich, wo die anderen sind. Und das sieht man ja auch an dem Money-Market-Share, der Nokia, LG und die dritte...
Wahrscheinlich Samsung oder Sony Ericsson....
haben irgendwie zusammen sogar noch weniger Gewinn als Apple.
Jaja klar, das ist ja alles...
Das ist nichts.
Ich glaube, das war so ein... Der Vibrator ging an.
Ja, wir haben ja hier auch ganz tolle neue Features hier, ne?
Ich möchte mal ein bisschen... Ich hab ja mal in meinem Rechner herumgeschraubt, da möchte ich ein bisschen drüber erzählen. Ich glaube, das interessiert auch.
Huckel hat die Home-Taste gedrückt. Deswegen musst du jetzt... Worüber möchtest du reden? Max hat das Wort.
Da haben mich auch unglaublich viele Leute nachgefragt, nachdem ich das getwittert habe. Ich hab mich ja von dir anstecken lassen. Ja, als ich neugierend an deinem MacBook saß, an diesem Sauschnellen mit der SSD drinnen, da war ich ziemlich begeistert davon und hab gedacht, das will ich auch. Dann bin ich neulich losgezogen und hab mir so eine SSD geholt. Wie groß? 128.
Wie teuer?
250.
Die selbe, die ich habe?
Sie selber. Also die gleiche, vermutlich.
Selbe Modell, meinte ich.
Und weil 128 GB jetzt ein bisschen wenig sind, wenn man allein 80 GB Rohdaten Podcasts rumliegen hat, da wollte ich dann noch eine große Platte dazu und habe meinen Superdrive geopfert und habe mir stattdessen eine zweite Platte da eingebaut.
Und den Rahmen hast du ja auch gekauft.
Und habe mir diesen Rahmen gekauft, dieses OptiBay heißt das. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich mir einen originalen Feld schon gekauft habe.
OptiBay.
Von wem ist das? Irgend so eine winzig kleine Bude.
OptiBay halt.
Kann sein.
Ist das der Rahmenkostepfiff?
Also ich habe 45 plus Lieferung.
Für den Rahmen?
Ja, ja.
Das ist nicht plötzlich.
Das sollte das Original sein.
Also das ist halt das.
45.
Das ist halt so ein, das ist halt, also das ist wirklich. Ne, ich hab's bei Ebay, irgendwie bei Ebay Deutschland bei irgendjemanden geholt. Das hat auch, das kam relativ flott. Und dann hab ich mich da an diese nervenaufreibende Tätigkeit begangen, da so ein Laufwerk auszuwechseln. Ich hab mir irgendwann mal vorgenommen, dass ich, also irgendwann gesagt, für so Laptops, da bin ich einfach nicht, ist meine Feinmotorik nicht gut genug. Ich hab diverse Male probiert, irgendwas an einem Laptop selber zu machen, und es ist immer gnadenlos gescheitert. Bis hin zu der Schrauben übrig geblieben sind und ähnliche Späße. Welches Modell hast du? Ich hab das letzte 15 Zoll MacBook Pro, wo man noch den Akku rausnehmen konnte. Und dann hab ich mir bei iFixit, die kennen wahrscheinlich, also weil auch viele nach Einbau- und Leitung gefragt haben, das ist so eine Webseite, wo man so wunderschöne Bilderkurse kriegt, wie man so an seinem MacBook irgendwas macht. Da war eine Anleitung drin und die hab ich mir mal angeguckt und die sah so aus wie...
Eine Anleitung jetzt konkret für diesen Austausch?
Na, wie man den Supertreif ausbaut und wieder einbaut. Beziehungsweise stand da nur Ausbau drin, das hab ich dann erst gemerkt, als das vor mir lag.
Du baust das auseinander, viel Spaß. Du hast sicherlich diese kleine Schraube auch...
Das war eine Anleitung mit zwölf Schritten und fünf davon ging allein darum, bis man den Akku draußen hatte. Dann hab ich gedacht, oder den Deckel ab.
Was muss man denn da machen?
Du nimmst das Ding um, nimmst den Akku raus.
Also erst mal machst du unten den Deckel ab?
Hier ist ja ein kleiner Deckel vorne. Das ist ja wirklich nur so. Hier ist ja noch die Trennung. Dann kann ich einfach hier das abnehmen. Dann ist der Deckel ab und dann ist der Akku drunter.
Ah ja, stimmt.
Und dann ist hier der Akku, den nimmt man raus. Dann ist hier die SSD drin, wie man leicht sehen kann.
Die ist auch hinreichend, wie man jetzt sehen kann.
Die ist hinreichend leicht zu entfernen.
Wir können das sehen.
Die SSD hast du jetzt dahin gemacht, wo die Originalplatte war. Die Originalplatte ist jetzt im Superdrive Schacht.
Die ist im Superdrive Schacht, genau.
Das heißt, du bootest jetzt von der SSD natürlich.
Ich boot von der SSD.
Warum hast du nicht die SSD in den Schacht gemacht? Da ist doch normalerweise das System drauf. Und das, was man normalerweise nicht mal eben austauschen will. Ich würde ja eher die fette Platte leicht zu tauschen machen.
Jetzt kann man sich dann aussuchen, von welchen man bootet. Das ist egal. Also könnte man ja auch tauschen und trotzdem von den anderen booten.
Ich glaube, das würde gehen, ja. Ich hätte es auch andersrum machen können. Ich habe mir ehrlich gesagt keine großen Gedanken drum gemacht. Und dann nimmt man den Boden ab. Und dann ist man eigentlich schon am Gerät dran. Und das Einzige, was wirklich dem Superdrive im Weg liegt, ist das Kamerakabel. Weil hier oben ist ja so eine kleine Kamera eingebaut. Das geht dann einmal so rum. Und das ist verklebt. Das muss man abziehen. Das Abziehen geht relativ leicht. Und dann ist es halt verklebt. Dann muss man es lösen. Und dann kann man mit ein paar Schritten das Superdrive rausholen. Dann musste ich an diesem OptiBay-Adapter noch so ein kleines Teil wieder dran schrauben. Das musste ich vom CD-ROM-Laufwerk abschrauben. So ein Winkel quasi. Und dann war das da irgendwie alles drin. Und das Einzige, womit ich wirklich Probleme hatte, war eben das... Pizzeriere Rippen. Genau, das geht irgendwie nicht mehr.
Keine Ahnung, warum, ich hab echt...
Was dieser Superdrive soll, weiß ich je nie.
Aber ich kann keine CD's mehr.
Aber brennen musst du mal probieren jetzt.
Genau, dass ich dieses Kamera-Kabel, da hatte ich echt pizzerliche Probleme, das wieder dran zu kriegen. Und irgendwann schnappt es dann aber fast wie von selber. Und dann hab ich es wieder zusammengebaut. Und seitdem hab ich da eine SSD drinne, eine 128er und eine schöne 500 GB Festplatte. Und das ist rattenschnell, das ist echt sagenhaft. Also ich hätte...
Wo hast du denn dein Home?
Mein Home ist auch auf der SSD. Wobei ich ein paar Verzeichnisse... Also ich hab hier das iTunes-Verzeichnis und das Movies-Verzeichnis, das Pictures-Verzeichnis und so ne Sachen, die hab ich alle per Sim-Link auf die externe Festplatte gepackt. Hab da jetzt auf der SSD... Wie viel hab ich noch frei? Ach, das Download-Verzeichnis noch natürlich. Hab da noch 51 GB frei drauf, was ja jetzt so ein ganz schöner Wert ist. Und ja, und das ist... Der Unterschied ist so groß, dass ich es am Anfang ernsthaft nicht geglaubt hatte, dass es stimmt, weil ich hab... Vorher, nach dem Login zum Beispiel, war das so, dass das so, bis alle Apps da waren, ich hab einen Haufen Startobjekte, dass da so, ich schätz mal, so zwei Minuten vergingen, bis das alles so gestartet war. Und das ist jetzt ein Prozess, der dauert unter zehn Sekunden. Das ist wirklich so... alles da.
Ah, ich will auch.
Das ist echt...
und hier so... 250, ja. Und hier so, iCarl ist einfach...
Aber iCarl ist bei mir auch schnell da.
Aber es ist alles dann da.
Das Mädel ist da.
Also iCarl ist eine der wenigen Applikationen, die wirklich...
Aber du hast doch keine Termine, oder?
Was?
Also iCarl hat bei mir vorher extrem lange gebraucht. Es ist einfach durch die Bank weg schneller. Und was ich... also ich hab jetzt so ein bisschen überlegt, nehme ich mehr RAM, ich hab vier Gigabyte in dem Ding drin. Dann hätte ich jetzt auf acht Gigabyte aufrüsten können, was mich so, ich glaube so... was kostet acht Gigabyte zurzeit, so 350 oder sowas? Oder nehme ich jetzt eine SSD, was im Endeffekt sogar günstiger war. Und eben dieses, was vorher war, wenn der RAM voll wurde, dann wurde der Rechner unglaublich langsam. Das ist so fast bis zum Stillstand. Und das ist jetzt einfach nicht mehr der Fall. Also der RAM ist voll und man kann weiterarbeiten. Ist jetzt vielleicht nicht so super rasend, schnell wie vorher. Also das ist so eine der besseren SSDs, die ich jemals in meinem Leben... Die Verscheidung, die ich gemacht habe. Und so dieses alte Mehr-RAM-Hilft-Immer, würde ich jetzt erst mal kurzzeitig sagen. Klar, wenn man zu wenig RAM hat, hat man zu wenig RAM. Dann sollte man noch ein bisschen mehr reinstecken.
RAM hilft auf jeden Fall auch noch.
Klar, aber SSD ist auch...
Ich hab das ja hier bei meinem MacBook gemacht. Nachdem ich bei meinem alten die SSD drin hatte, dann fühlte sich das neue so langsam, dass ich auch irgendwas tun musste. Und dann hab ich schon einfach RAM reingesteckt und das Ding auf 8 GB erhöht. Und dann war's erträglich wieder, aber mit 4 kann man irgendwie so einen Mac nicht mehr betreiben.
Das war mal...
Was ich hier kürzlich gelesen hab zu diesem Thema SSD, also da gibt's kurz nachdem die SSDs da so rausgekommen sind, haben sie so rausgefunden, dass irgendwie beim Löschen von Dateien oder Daten, dass es da zu einer Performance-Degradation kommt, weil irgendwie da die SSD dann irgendwie Daten hin- und herschaufeln muss, keine Ahnung. Da haben sie doch dieses Trim-Command irgendwie hinzugefügt, um das effizienter zu gestalten. Und da hab ich letztens gelesen, dass Apple, also das macOS dieses Trim-Command gar nicht unterstützt und deswegen da die SSDs bei macOS noch gar nicht so richtig voll an der Kante fahren.
Jo, wenn die nämlich erstmal voll sind, das heißt wenn alle Blöcke irgendwann mal belegt waren, dann weiß halt der Controller von SSD nicht mehr, welcher Block nun wirklich frei ist und welcher nicht. Also wo er einfach so draufschreiben kann, ohne dass er erst, wie soll man das erklären, angenommen die Blöcke auf so eine SSD, die sind, sagen wir mal, acht Kilobyte groß. Und dein Feinde oder so will jetzt aber nur vier Kilobyte schreiben, dann weiß der der SSD-Controller nicht, ob die anderen vier Kilobyte von diesem acht Kilobyte-Block, ob er die aufheben muss oder nicht. Weil der weiß ja nicht, ob das vorher gelöscht wurde oder nicht. Also muss er die erstmal einlesen und muss sie dann wieder rausschreiben und irgendwie so. Und deswegen gibt es dieses Trim-Kommando, mit dem kann das OS sagen, ok, lösch mal diesen Block. Und der sagt dem Controller auch, der ist jetzt nicht mehr das, was da liegt, ist nicht mehr wichtig, du kannst einfach drüber bügeln. Und dieses Kommando gibt es nicht in OS X. Aber es gibt wohl, ich habe es gerade schon geguckt, leider nicht gefunden, vielleicht findest du es einer hier im Chat oder so, es gibt ein Tool, was irgendwer geschrieben hat, was sich die freie Blogliste einfach holt von dem File System. Und dieses Trim-Kommando irgendwie von Hand wohl einfach an die Platte schickt. Das muss man so ab und zu mal von Hand machen. Ist jetzt zwar nicht so super cool, aber sorgt dafür, dass man seine Performance wieder so ein bisschen wieder aufpeppen kann.
Also überhaupt ist dieser SSD-Support von Mac OS X noch sehr verbesserungswürdig. Also was ich zum Beispiel in irgendwelchen Foren gelesen habe, dass dieser berühmte Sudden-Motion-Sensor, also der feststellt, wenn er das Gefühl hat, dass die Platte im freien Fall sein könnte und dann lieber die Plattenköpfe wegzieht, dass der wohl auch bei SSDs noch läuft. Mit anderen Worten, dass man...
Der sagt, der SSD auch, mach dich mal kurz aus.
Genau.
Kann man ausschalten.
Also, dass man unbedingt diesen Sudden-Motion-Sensor abschalten sollte, wenn man eine SSD hat, wenn man sonst nicht die ganze Geschwindigkeit wieder, ähm, ja, in einigen Situationen wieder verschenkt. Also da kann Apple definitiv noch einiges machen.
Also ich hab hier gerade noch... Ich hab hier gerade noch ein Artikel gefunden vom 14. Juni, wo steht, Apple laying groundwork for trim support in future SSD-based Macs, aber...
Weil jetzt angezeigt wird, da der halt trim support.
Aber kürzlich hab ich das eben gerade wiedergelesen, dass irgendwie das Mac OS wohl immer noch nicht supportet.
Mich würde es nicht wundern, wenn das Problem sich schon mit 10, 6, 5 ändert, weil sie ja jetzt... Aber es ist nicht das erste Mal, dass SSDs aufliefern.
Die verkaufen die schon seit einem Jahr oder so.
Mit R und allem, ja. Nee, stimmt. Das ist mir auch ein Rätsel.
Vielleicht sind ihre Fallsystem-Engineers und so jetzt alle mit dem neuen Apple FS beschäftigt und es gibt keine Ressourcen mehr für HFS und wissen schon.
Das Fallsystem-Thema, oh Mann. Ja, es gibt überhaupt keine Fallsystem-News. Und irgendwie hab ich das Gefühl, das hat so das Potenzial für die Big News des nächsten Jahres. Also wenn 10.7 nicht All About Fallsystem ist. Ohne Snapshots können sie gleich auf 10.8 gehen.
Ich würde eher sagen, 10.7 ist All About Syncing.
Das finde ich, ist Teil dieser ganzen Geschichte. Also Snapshots, Syncing, das hängt einfach alles so miteinander zusammen. Wie wollen sie Backups, ich meine auch dieses Time Machine, was sie da derzeit machen, das ist einfach mit schöner Legend.
So müssen das andere erstmal hinkriegen. Also ich hab jetzt richtig gehört, dass jemand hatte einen Plattencrash. Hab ich mir gestern glaube ich nochmal erzählen lassen, oder was vorgestern, weiß ich nicht, hatte einen Plattencrash, also Platte komplett im Arsch. Händler gegangen, hat sich eine neue einbauen lassen, alte war wirklich hinüber, man konnte nichts retten, er hatte wirklich eine leere Platte, hat die Snow Lappert CD eingelegt oder DVD. Snow Lappert hat gefragt, hast du Backup? Hat er sein Time Machine Volume angeschlossen? Hat er gesagt, hier Backup bitte von da einspielen, hat das gemacht und getan, war alles wieder so wie Tag vorher.
Ja, war das bei mir ja auch.
Ja, wie sich das gehört.
Das will man ja wohl auch erwarten. Also wenn dem jetzt nicht so wär, dann müsste man echt die Nase rümpfen. Das finde ich jetzt nicht so.
Ja, aber das ist schon ziemlich cool, weil...
Ja, aber schreibt dir ein kleines Skript, was eine zwei Gigabyte große Datei alle zehn Sekunden irgendwie einen Byte ändert und das kriegst du einfach nicht abgebildet auf Time Machine. Das ist einfach schon gar nicht über W-Laden. Der kann gar nicht die Daten so schnell...
Also weil er dich Block-Level macht, sondern nur File-Level.
File-Level macht, genau so. Und der kann die Daten auch gar nicht so schnell wegschreiben und dann läuft das auch so scheiße schnell voll. Also dieses Volume läuft dadurch auch zu schnell voll. Sinnlos. Du änderst einen Byte und generierst Gigabyte an Surplus. Und irgendwann kommt er dir mit, ich muss jetzt mal die letzten zehn Monate löschen.
Und das dauert richtig lange.
Und das dauert auch nochmal richtig lange. Das dauert richtig lange. Es ist slow. Und vor allem, ich hab's sehr häufig schon erlebt, dass das Ganze sich dann auch in so eine Schleife gefangen hat. Also gerade wenn du über WLAN machst, wo dann auch irgendwann gar nichts mehr vorankommt. Also wo er es nicht schafft, in abgebrochene Backups überhaupt erstmal festzustellen, wo er aufgehört hat und wieder weiterzumachen.
Ich lösche dann den In-Progress-Orner und fang nochmal frisch an.
Genau, man muss auch richtig manuell beigehen und da irgendwie händisch Sachen löschen, wo man ja nun wirklich eigentlich nicht beigehen wollen würde.
Und das dauert auch sehr lange?
Das dauert auch sehr lange, um überhaupt wieder Backups zu haben. Also ich hab das ganz oft gehabt, dass einfach dieser ganze Backup-Prozess komplett eingefroren war und sich nicht mehr aus sich selbst heraus aktivieren konnte.
Also das Beste, was ich in der Hinsicht immer eigentlich, oder sagen wir mal so, am besten hat es bei mir immer funktioniert, echt mit meiner Firewire 800-Platte, da konnte ich mich nicht beklagen, aber sobald das irgendwie mal USB ging und länger gedauert hat und so, da hatte ich auch diverse Mal dieses Phänomen mit diesem Festhängen, abbrechen, dann löschen, was dann tausende Dateien, keine Ahnung, was er da tut, aber es dauert wirklich extrem lange. Und dann ärgere ich mich jedes Mal, dass ich nicht R-RF gemacht habe, sondern über ein Finder gelöscht habe, weil der Finder ja irgendwie jedes Fall nochmal dreimal umdreht, bevor es dann wirklich löscht. Was ja auch komisch ist, ne? Also warum...
Bei mir macht das immer noch mein FreeBSD und da flutscht alles. Da ist ja auch ein zweiter Rechner, der dann natürlich das Löschen übernimmt, das macht ja dann nicht mein Laptop, sondern ein anderer Rechner, vielleicht ist das dann ein bisschen performanter.
Sie müssen ein Fallsystem machen, was Snapshots kann. Du musst einfach zu jeder Sekunde einen Snapshot machen können. Du musst sagen können, den aktuellen Zustand und es muss auf Block-Level disbar sein. Und wenn da ein Byte sich in einem Gigabyte-Fall ändert, dann hat genau ein Datenblock gesichert zu werden und nicht mehr. Und vielleicht noch ein paar Directory-Notes drumherum und das war's. Und das muss in Windeseile schwuppdiwupp mal eben gehen und nicht so ein Gerödel.
Oder?
Ja, die machen schon was. Ich bin da optimistisch.
Die müssen einfach.
Das geht doch nicht weiter.
Nee, aber ich glaube, das wissen die schon selber auch, dass das stinkt. Also ich meine, Steve hat doch auch so eine Probleme. Steve sitzt doch auch zu Hause mit seinem Laptop und der hat doch genau diesen Frost. Das kann mir doch keiner erzählen, dass er den nicht hat.
Ja, der macht dann Schleidersitz und meditiert dann.
Nee, der ruft an und sagt, ey Jungs.
Mein ZFs will nicht.
Ich bin beunruhigt, dass er noch so viel Zeit hat, um so eine Scheiße zu erzeugen wie Ping. Oder vielleicht ist das deshalb so scheiße, weil er sich die ganze Zeit nur um das Fallsystem kümmern.
Dann muss das Dateisystem extrem geil werden.
Nee, aber jetzt mal ehrlich, ich stell mir ganz oft dann in so Situationen vor, wie Steve dann zu Hause sitzt und irgendwie stürzt ihm das iTunes ab oder... Ich meine, wie ist der wohl dann so drauf? Feuert der einfach eins von seinen 10.000 Notebooks aus dem Regal irgendwie direkt an die Wand?
Also wahrscheinlich beantwortet er dann hin und wieder mal so ein paar Mails einfach.
Wenn er so richtig schön geladen ist.
Als anders!
Oh, mein Macintosh hatte Datenverlust. You're holding a bra.
Er kommt dann in den Zyniker Mode.
Ach ja, Max, du hast ja noch mehr Hardware getestet.
Ja, ich hab mir jetzt im Büro so ein Magic-Touchpad gegeben lassen.
Wir haben das im Club gehabt.
Das heißt übrigens Trackpad.
Abzahl Magic. Nee. Es kommt trotzdem nicht an das Trackpad ran. Vom Macbook, finde ich. Warum? Ist das nicht dasselbe? Zum einen ist es zu groß. Das klingt jetzt vielleicht total dämlich. Aber ich mag das ja. Ich glaube, ich mag diese Aufteilung. Ich mag dieses Trackpad unten, Tastatur oben. Man kann so schön leicht wechseln. Also ich möchte eigentlich nach wie vor diesen Unterbau gerne so nutzen. Und dieses Trackpad ist schon so. Das ist für die Aluminium-Apple-Tastatur gemacht, dass man das so direkt daneben liegt. Die habe ich jetzt nicht, weil das ein Windows-PC ist und weil ich da keinen Bock hatte, mit einer Mac-Tastatur darum zu friemeln. Und dann steht das so daneben und dann lege ich es manchmal davor, so auch in die Mitte, und dann liegt es aber im Weg, weil dann will man ja doch manchmal tippen und dann ist es ein bisschen zu groß.
Und du benutzt dieses Trackpad am Laptop?
Ich benutze es an einem Desktop-PC. Windows 7.
Du benutzt das Magic Trackpad an einem Windows-Rechner?
Das ist die späte Rache. An meinem MacBook hab ich doch ein Trackpad. Da brauch ich doch kein Trackpad.
Aber ist denn die volle Funktionalität da unter Windows überhaupt abrufbar?
Nee, das Wesentliche ist da. Also ich kann draggen, also ich kann scrollen.
Aber die Maus? Du benutzt doch jetzt Windows, ne?
Im Augenblick wurde das natürlich wieder Mac erweitert, ja?
Ja, aber ich hab früher so einen Verdacht gehabt, dass die Maus sich anders bewegt bei Windows. Kannst du das unterstreichen, dass das so ist? Ist das noch so? War das jemals so? Weißt du, was ich meine?
Ancelerator Mode oder was?
Ja, diese Beschleunigung ist anders.
Ja, ich glaub, die ist wesentlich geringer.
Die ist linearer, glaub ich.
Es gibt fast keine Beschleunigung sozusagen.
Irgendwas machen die da bei MechOS. Ich hab das nie ganz verstanden, was die da tun, aber irgendwie, ich schubs die Maus an so einem PC und die bewegt sich an. Vielleicht bin ich auch paranoid.
Der cursor hat auch eine andere Farbe.
Wir hatten ja das Trackpad, wie heißt das denn, Magic Trackpad? Auch im Club. Und das erste Mal hab ich ja gefragt, wie viel das eigentlich kostet, und dann meinte er 69 Euro. Dann hab ich das Ding da in der Hand gehabt und dachte mir, What?
Welche Strafgebühr?
Die Maus kostet auch 30, oder?
Die kostet auch 69? Für 30, da kriegst du noch...
Für 30, da kriegst du...
Feuchten Händedruck.
Ich hab das ziemlich gerade gekauft.
Ein iPad-Netzteil kostet nur 30 Euro?
Ja, 28.
Ein guter Preis eigentlich. Aber ich fand das Trackpad auch nicht so spektakulär. Erstens sind ja die Klicks, ne? Das fand ich ja witzig, die Klicks haben halt unten so zwei Nasen. Links und rechts hat das Trackpad so. Und das sind die Klicks. Das sind die Dinger, die klicken, wenn du drückst.
Das ist links und rechts. Das Coole ist, das sind beides die gleichen. Das heißt, wenn du einen reinklickst, dann ist der andere auch reingeklickt.
Oder die haben beide einen Sensor.
Und der merkt über den Touch, wo du gerade bist, welche Seite du geklickt hast. Also eigentlich auch nur ein Button, aber mit zwei physikalischen rausguckenden Gummifüßen.
Ich find ja total scheiße, warum das Ding so angewinkelt ist. Ich wette das ja gern, dass es so richtig schön flach auf dem Tisch liegt. Und das einzige, könnte man jetzt natürlich sagen, ja ja, kriegen die Technik nicht so dünn. Die Technik ist ja überhaupt nicht das Problem. Ich hab mir auch so ein paar Zerlegefotos angeguckt. Die Technik steckt im Wesentlichen in der Fläche drin. Und dahinten ist wirklich nur die Batterie.
Dann säge dir das ab und mach dir doch ein Kabel ran. Du hast ja auch schon mal ein USB-Kabel an so einer Maus irgendwie gelötet, ne?
Ja, das wäre tatsächlich ein gangbarer Weg, würde ich sagen, dass man das dahinten irgendwie...
Sollen einfach so Mini-USB-Stecker daran machen, ne? Und dann soll man sich selber seinen Kabel von Apple noch mal 15 Euro, wenn man will, dass man gleich per Kabel irgendwie hat.
Ja, so ein schickes Dog-Connector-Kabel.
Das könnte man auch gleich zum Laden benutzen. Eigentlich wär das total cool.
Von Alienware, diese PC-Gamer-Bude, die haben ja so eine Gamer-Mäuse, so Pro-Gamer-Mäuse, und die sind geradlos. Und da kannst du dann eben genau auch ein USB-Kabel ranstecken zum irgendwie jetzt Direct Mode und Laden und so. Fand ich auch gut.
Ja, also du warst nicht überzeugt.
Es ist gut und ich werd's auch weiterhin nutzen, aber perfekt ist was anderes. Also das ist jetzt nicht das, was ich mir oft hatte. Ich hatte mir ja oft, dass ich das gleiche Erlebnis, was ich hier so auf MacBook mit Tastatur und Mouse habe und so, und Trackpad habe, dass ich das jetzt auch an einem Desktop-Rechner haben kann, und dass es leider nicht in Erfüllung gab.
Das ist halt so, weißt du, du hast halt so dieses iPad und da ist ja so Multitouch und so mit dem Content hin und her schieben total super toll, ne? Und will man ja auch gar nicht anders haben und fluffy und snappy, so. Und dann hast du hier auf deinem Mac hast du Tastatur und mit dem Daumen bist du auch immer ganz schnell am Touchpad, aber da ist dann so ein extra Touchgerät, was irgendwie, du musst halt trotzdem, also so, so, weiß nicht, irgendwie so richtig nach Must-Have-Gadget fühlte sich das einfach nicht an. Nee, ist es auch nicht.
Ist man aber vielleicht auch erst mal eine Weile benutzt, beformert es so.
Aber ich hätte, ja, aber ich finde da die Magic Mouse, was heißt die Magic? Ich komm da eben nicht mehr mit dem Namen. Mighty Warfoia. Mighty Warfoia, ja. Und Magic finde ich irgendwie dann, die Magic Mouse, echt toller als Steuerungsgerät sogar.
Ich bin mit der Magic Mouse eigentlich auch zufrieden, vor allem, weil es eigentlich die erste Mouse ist, die auf diesem Tisch hier funktioniert.
Und es ist auch vor allen Dingen die erste Mouse, die...
Also einen weißen, glatten Tisch. Es stören mich aber ein paar Sachen auch noch. Und zwar dieses Scrollen auf der Mouse. Das kommt mir doch sehr häufig in die Quere.
Bei Google Maps zum Beispiel.
Da hast du auf einmal so einen Zoom und die ganze Zeit zooms rein und raus. Genau, diese Entscheidung, dass man sozusagen hier nur mit einem Finger scrollt, während man das auf dem Trackpad mit zwei macht, das verstehe ich nicht. Ich meine, ich hätte ja auch zwei nehmen können. Ich meine, es geht auch mit zwei, aber es geht halt auch mit einer. Aber diese Scroll-Bewegung fühle ich auch schon einfach so durch. Ich meine, so eine Maus will man ja auch ein bisschen kraulen. So wie so ein Hamster. Wenn ich so meinen Evil Blick habe, so mit weißem Anzug, so meine Sessel sitzen und so meine Angora-Katze kraule, das ist ja dann mit der Maus genauso.
Ja, nee, aber ich finde, die Magic-Maus ist auf jeden Fall die beste Maus, die Apple seit langem gebaut hat. Das kann man schon mal sagen.
Also ich hab die immer damals auch geholt und hab sie nach zwei oder drei Tagen wirklich entnervt, zurückgegeben, weil ich sie so unerträglich fand. Also ich hab offensichtlich sowieso kein Händchen mehr für Mäuse.
Ich hab aber auch ein paar Tage gebraucht, bis man so drin war. Am Anfang war es schon eine Umstellung. Ich dachte, shit, meine Mighty-Maus war irgendwie besser, aber es hat sich geswitcht.
Also diese Sache hier mit meinen zwei Rechnern und jeder hat irgendwie seine eigene Magic-Maus und so ein Wireless-Keyboard, das ist geil.
Das muss man auch mal sagen. Tim sitzt original an einem Tisch mit zwei Rechnern, zwei Tastaturen und zwei Mäusen, während wir uns mit drei Rechnern irgendwie an einem Tisch...
Ich kann auch ein iPad rausholen.
Warum sitze ich dich eigentlich bei dir mit drüben?
Das nennt man Hackordnung. Weiß nicht, du setzt dich ja immer freiwillig dahin.
Weil da kein Platz ist.
Ja, eigentlich wollte ich ja hier auch mal einen runden Tisch reinbauen, aber das haben halt einfach die Investitionen bisher noch nicht hergegeben.
Mit dem runden Tisch kommst du 20 Jahre zu spät.
Ich muss so viel Geld in eine Sushi investieren.
Kriegst du alle zugeschmissen über Flatter.
Ja, aber da geht es doch noch hin, in deinem Magen.
Ja, geil. Wenn wir mal bei Hardware waren, ich muss ganz kurz auch einen Einschub machen.
Ich hab hier nur so einen halben Tisch. Ich hab hier auch noch einen Mischpult stehen.
Wir ändern das demnächst mal. Ich komm dann mal zu dir rüber, Schatzi. Ihr wisst ja, wir sind ja auch hier so ein bisschen die Hardware-Buster. Ihr hookt ja auch. Wir haben hier Arduinos. Und zwar hier ist das Teil Arduino Due Milanove. Was heißt 2000, ne? So war's. Due wie 2 und Mila wie 1000. Und Nove wie keine Ahnung. Und da gibt's jetzt auch ein neues Gerät. Das heißt Arduino Uno. Und der Unterschied, was gerade für Mac-User interessant ist, bei dem alten Due Milanove brauchte man, um an diese Rele von diesem Gerät ranzukommen, brauchte man einen FTDI-Treiber. Das wissen wahrscheinlich alle, die so ein Ding haben. Die anderen blicken jetzt eh nichts mehr.
Was ist denn ein FTDI-Treiber?
Na, da ist so ein Baustein drauf, der von USB nach irgendwie seriell wandelt. Auf diesem Arduino. Damit man halt das Ding per USB an seinen Rechner anschließt und dann kannst du an die Serielle von dem Atmel, mit dem man da eigentlich rumbasteln will. Ist so ein Fertigplatinchen mit seinem Atmel drauf. Und bei dem neuen Arduino Uno, da haben sie den rausgeschmissen, den FTDI-Chip und haben dafür einen weiteren Atmel mit USB-Features draufgemacht. Und der macht jetzt auch die Serielle bis zum Mac durch, aber man braucht keinen Treiber mehr, sondern der kommt gleich automatisch. Das ist schon mal das coole Feature, das heißt, ein Treiber fällt weg. Zweitens ist er wohl von der Latenz schneller, das heißt, man kann ein bisschen mehr so USB-Features machen, weil es ein bisschen flotter ist. Und drittens, man könnte die Firmware von diesem USB-Atmel auch noch ändern, das heißt, man kann dann auch seine eigene USB-Device-Nummer da drauf klatschen oder was auch immer man davor hat. Also man hat viel mehr Freiheiten und das gibt es jetzt seit ein paar Tagen wohl. Und hier in Berlin bei Sego haben sie die auch schon. Ich hab mir schon einen eingeschoppt und funktioniert super.
Der taucht auch so richtig im Networks Preferences-Paint taucht dann gleich Arduino Uno auf. Also die ist richtig schön integriert sozusagen.
In Network?
Ja, weil es halt sehr reell ist und weil die denken, das könnte ja Modem sein oder irgendwie so. Apple ist doch noch ein bisschen so wie früher.
Okay, aber steckst halt dran, ist sofort da und das ist schon mal gut.
Ja, ansonsten die Hardware ist genau kompatibel für diese ganzen, wie heißen die Dinger, die man da draufstecken kann?
Ja, hier halt diese Extenten...
Was heißt jetzt diesen Stecker, der da draufsteckt?
Nee, aber da sind so zwei so eine Steckleiste und man kann da auch noch so welche draufstecken, aber ich hab jetzt auch...
Ja, vergessen.
Jedenfalls ist das alles gleich geblieben und das heißt, man kann seinen alten Arduino irgendwie in die Ecke schmeißen, oder falls man sich einen neuen kauft, kauft man sich den ohne und packt sein steckbares Modul, wie auch immer das jetzt heißt, oben drauf und es geht alles weiter so wie vorher. Und wollte ich nur Shields, genau hier sagt es einer. Shields heißen, kann man da oben draufstecken und die sind weiterhin kompatibel, habe ich schon getestet. Also kann ich nur empfehlen, ist voll toll. Preis ist der gleiche wie beim alten.
Was passt denn damit?
Na ich macht auch hier im Club dieses riesen Flughafen oder Bahnhof-Display und dieses Arduino-Teil. Also auf lange Sicht macht man sich natürlich sein eigenes Board. Wenn man aber erstmal so ein bisschen Prototypen will, dann nimmt man halt so ein Arduino, weil da ist das mit der Stromversorgung schon drauf. Du hast halt deine Serielle per USB, was ich ja später alles nicht mehr brauche, wenn das eigene Board mal fertig ist. Aber so zum Debuggen und Prototypen ist so ein Arduino voll toll.
Auf lange Sicht macht man sich natürlich sein eigenes Board. Das finde ich tatsächlich eine gewagte Aussage.
Weil ich kann mir ja nicht, ich brauch 20 Boards irgendwann mal. Für jede Leiste von diesem Display will ich ein eigenes Board machen. Und weil wir wollen es noch ein bisschen schneller machen, als es schon ist. Und da müsste ich ja 20 Arduinos kaufen, da wäre ich ja bei 500 Euro. Das geht natürlich nicht, sondern...
Gibt's die nicht auch billiger schon? Also ich meine, brauchst du ja nicht jedes Mal mit USB und allem, sondern...
Es gibt die kleine, aber die sind nicht billiger.
Und vor allem ist es ja auch nicht die Größe, die ich brauche. Ich muss es ja fertig da in dieses Display einbauen. Das hat ja schon eine vorgegebene physikalische Größe. Und die muss ich halt genauso wieder dann irgendwann selber fräsen im Klop, 20 Mal. Oder wahrscheinlich eher bei PCB-Pool gibt man irgendwie seinen Layout und seinen Design ab. Und die machen einem die Platinen und dann kommen die wieder. Und dann wird's ein bisschen billiger. Vor allem, wenn man so noch viele haben will, dann geht's eigentlich vom Preis.
Ja, ich hab ja... Jetzt wurde gerade dein iPad rausgeholt, also ich hab mir ja auch mal von der Firma das iPad ausgeliehen für... Eigentlich wollte ich es nur ein Wochenende, dann hatte ich es drei Wochen. Ich hätte es ja nicht gedacht, also ich hatte ja letztes Mal schon erzählt, dass ich als ich meinen Rechner auseinandergeschraubt hatte, hatte ich ja auch dann schön die Anleitung von ifixit.com hier auf dem iPad daneben liegen. Das war so richtig schon mein Information-Tablet, ja. Und halt irgendwie dann so ein paar Mal auch im Bett gelegen, noch so ein bisschen gebraust und so. Was halt echt cool ist, ist so dieses mit der Hand einfach so in diesem Content rumfingern und groß schieben und hochschieben und scrollen und wischen mit dieser neuen Twitter-App, die ich ja auch noch mal ausprobiert. Und sowas so kommt halt schon so an dieses, was man immer so sagt aus diesem Minority Report-Film, diese Interfaces, so mit diesem Wischen und Hin- und Herziehen kommt schon echt ganz nahe dran. Der einzige wirkliche Kritikpunkt, das ist das Wort, finde ich, ist die Auflösung. Also zum Lesen finde ich es zu anstrengend. Ja, also ich habe jetzt versucht, so ein paar E-Books mal zu lesen oder so, wenn du längere Blog-Posts liest, das finde ich schon ein bisschen ätzend. Also es kann sein, dass es durch das Retina-Display kommt, dass einem das so auffällt, dass die Schrift so fitzelt und irgendwie unscharf ist. Aber ich habe mich halt ertappt, dass ich immer ganz viel ranzoome und immer so auch horizontal sozusagen hin und her schiebe, weil ich so groß gescrollt habe, dass es halt größer ist als das Display. Und dann so lesen und das...
Also du bist halt dafür, dass das iPad auch mit Retina-Auflösung rauskommt. Also dass sie einfach mal verdoppeln sollten.
Ich frage mich, ob sie das schaffen.
Wenn sie das schaffen, also...
Wieso nicht?
Naja, weil es gibt nicht so viele...
Das DPI von dem iPad ist doch weniger als von so einem 3GS gewesen, oder? Na das heißt, wenn die verdoppeln, sind die noch nicht bei der Größe der DPI-Zahl wie beim iPhone 4.
Ja, ich meine, wenn sie da was ändern, dann verdoppeln sie. Und das wird dann auch schon erreichen.
Aber dann wären sie bei 2000 irgendwas mal...
Ja, es ist halt einfach die Daten...
Ja, das wäre schon für so ein kleines Teil doch ganz ordentlich.
Ja, aber damit ist... Ich meine, irgendwer wird es demnächst machen, wenn die Techno-Bloode, wie kommen die das?
Sie haben 132 PPI gerade und das iPhone hat ja das iPhone 4 326 oder so was.
Ja, das heißt, danach wären sie gerade mal 100, was? 132. Dann sind sie gerade mal bei 264. Ist ja nix.
Ja, aber das würde es schon vollbringen.
Ja, klar wird es das vollbringen, aber ich glaube, das gibt die Harte ja einfach noch nicht her. Es gibt noch nicht so eine Grafikprozesseur für so kleine Teile, die das so können.
Naja.
So.
Da kommt halt der A5 oder der A6 rein.
Na, den bauen sie sich halt selber.
Natürlich, dass das irgendwann mal kommt, ist ja gar keine Frage, aber ich glaube, also vielleicht...
Da wissen wir dann auch, warum Apple sich Anteile von Power VR gekauft hat.
Also, das ist auch so die Sache. Ich finde ja auch so...
Aber es gibt ja noch einen zweiten Aspekt. Es ist ja gar nicht mehr nur so, dass der Grafikstein in der Lage sein muss, das rumzublitten, sondern dass die Masse an Grafik, die das sozusagen in den Applikationen erzeugt, das macht die Apps größer. Und das ist wahrscheinlich auch recht nennenswert. Also sie werden auf jeden Fall den Speicher verdoppeln müssen bei diesem Gerät. Also mit 16 GB einsteigen, denke ich mal, ist es dann nicht...
Ja, aber das ist doch eh klar, dass das alles demnächst größer wird. Also auch diese 256 MB, dieses iPad-Gratenort, das könntest du ja beim nächsten Mal...
Das denke ich auch, dass sie mindestens alles wieder weiter haben. Ja, aber das wird dann auch erforderlich sein. Und zwar erforderlich, um sozusagen dasselbe zu tun, was sie jetzt auch schon machen, ohne dass sie jetzt erst mal...
Einen schicker, aber es ist nicht dasselbe. Sondern es ist einfach mal viel, viel geiler.
Das ist dann schicker, aber steht dir dann halt auch eben nicht für andere Sachen zur Verfügung. Sondern wenn du das auch noch haben willst, dann kannst du ihm auch gleich einen Gigabyte spendieren.
Aber ich meine, das war eindeutig für mich, das ist immer noch das größte Ding am iPhone 4, dieses Display. Also es ist einfach nie wieder schlechter, bitte.
Keine Frage.
Aber ich hab halt auch so bei dieser Benutzung halt auch so ein paar iPad-Only-Apps installiert und so. Und früher, oder bevor ich das jetzt so selber ausprobiert hatte, hatte ich ja echt so den Zweifel, ob jetzt wirklich diese iPad-Apps dann noch so viel mehr wertbringen, oder ob es nicht reicht, die iPhone-App da aufgepustet drauf zu fahren. Aber ich bin da echt ganz angetan von diesen ganzen Interfaces und Ups, die sie da so alle rausgetan haben. Für alles, was ich so auf dem iPhone hatte, habe ich mir mal die iPad-Variante geholt. Und war schon echt schick. Also vor allen Dingen dieses Twitter-Interface, das schockt auch echt ganz viele Leute. Hat man ja letztes Mal schon.
Das ist super, das ist echt.
Oder auch die Wetter-Applikation. Und natürlich die Nachttisch-Urapplikation, ganz wichtig.
Irgendwie fällt den Leuten das so richtig ein. Das ist massenhaft diese Nachttisch-Applikation.
Das ist wirklich schräg.
Das ist irgendwie die Taschenlampe des iPads.
Habt ihr denn hier dieses...
Ich hab keine, aber es gibt die massenhaft.
Jetzt gab's auch plötzlich eine mit so Röhrenoptik.
Ich hab hier gerade Flash auf meinem iPad.
Hat Flash gesagt. Ich hab gerade ne Vision. Wir brauchen Voice Detection und immer wenn der Erste, der in einer Sendung Flash sagt, kommt automatisch dieses Ding.
Ja, das muss ich ja gleich da her singen.
Aber welcher Knopf ist denn das? Welcher Knopf ist denn das?
Ich sing die wieder.
Wo ist denn dieser Flash-Knopf?
Es gibt keinen Flash-Knopf.
Nein, nein, Kreuz nach links. Nein, nein, nein.
Nein, nein, nein.
Aber es ist kurz genug, damit wir keine GEMA bezahlen.
Sehr gut.
Was ich sagen wollte, ich hab nämlich jetzt mal damit rum experimentiert, was man machen muss, damit das iPad als zweiter Bildschirm ist.
Läuft.
Hast du nicht gerade schon vielleicht erzählt?
Und hab damit Screen Recycler und einem VNC-Client auf dem iTeleport das Ganze gemacht. Das hat aber nicht so wirklich gut funktioniert. Jetzt hab ich hier viel zu viel Geld für das Programm R-Display ausgegeben, was jetzt mit einem quasi zweiten Monitor haben kann. Und was mir eben gerade durch Zufall aufgefallen ist, dass das nicht nur als Monitor funktioniert, sondern dass man auch aufs Display tippen kann und dann bewegt sich der Maus-Cursor dahin. Jetzt bin ich damit einfach mal auf YouTube gegangen und jetzt hab ich hier Flash auf dem iPad. Echt? Ja, und es ruckelt genauso wie das echte.
Flash auf dem iPad, jetzt bei Moba Max. Und es ruckelt.
Ja, aber es wird ja auch hin gestreamt.
Ja, das ist jetzt hier hart falsch gesagt, was ihr erwartet.
Das ist der externe Bildschirm von meinem... Aber ich hab auch Chrome auf dem iPad.
Aber das ist krass, das find ich mal cool.
Ja, das Display hab ich auch schon ein bisschen getestet, das ist cool.
7 Euro oder so was.
Da wollte Wolfram Alpha am Anfang mehr haben.
Diese unglaublich tolle Applikation, die es auch als Web-Applikation gab, die niemand wollte.
Ich hab mir, als sie den Preis runtergedreht haben, hab ich mehrere Wolfram Alpha gekauft.
Ja, hab ich auch. Und seitdem nie wieder benutzt.
Letztens wollte ich wissen, wie viel Kubikmeter Gold jemals auf der Erde gefördert wurden und wie viel das wert ist.
Das passt genau in ein Olympia-Becken, das ist nicht mehr.
Na, es waren irgendwie 30 Kubikmeter Gold wurden seit Anbeginn der Zeit bisher. 30 Kubikmeter?
Quatsch, nein, ein Olympia-Schwimmbecken voll.
Ja, nee, es war aber auf jeden Fall, also irgendeine Zahl war es auf jeden Fall die extrem wenig.
140.000 Tonnen Gold.
Auf jeden Fall irgendwie Wolfram Alpha eingetippt und so noch mal herausgefunden, dass das alles schon stimmt. Weil einfach schwer diese Materie.
Und ich hab auch das erste Mal die Abfrage gehabt, wo Wolfram Alpha einfach Delivered hat. Ich wollte wissen, wie viele 50 Kilometer mal 50 Kilometer Patches die Erdoberfläche hat. Also wenn ich die gesamte Erdoberfläche durch 50 Quadratkilometer, und das kannst du da einfach genauso eingeben. Surface of the Earth divided by 50 Quadratkilometer. Und dann rechnet dir der Penner das aus.
Ja und wir hätten halt irgendwie auch so 30 Kubikmeters Gold in US-Dollar. Und dann rechnet dir der aus, wie viel das wert ist. Und natürlich auch über die Zeit, irgendwie vor 100 Jahren, war das nur so und so viel wert.
Und vor allem die Leute denken, Google ist scary. Scary ist echt Wolfram Alpha. Das ist wirklich scary, weil da setzt es bei mir komplett aus. Das kann ich nicht mehr nachvollziehen, wie man in der.
Ob es von Wolfram Alpha auch mal eine Beta-Phase ist?
Okay, dann mach ich auch noch meinen lechten Witz machen.
Gibt es dann auch Wolfram Alpha Street View?
Hast du Nokia gemacht, der jetzt so was Street View Art ist?
Ich meine Wolfram Alpha Street View, was wäre denn das? Das wäre wahrscheinlich, du fährst durch die Straßen und siehst an jedem Haus gleich den durchschnittlichen Wasserverbrauch, Einkommensstatistiken und irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Numbers. Kondomverbrauch pro Woche, geteilt durch Gummibärchen, Bedarf des Stadtteils und der durchschnittlichen Anzahl gefälter Bäume im Umkreis des Baumes.
Ja, wir haben es verstanden.
Nokia macht jetzt auch so was Street View Artiges.
Du hast Nokia gesagt.
Ich habe Nokia gesagt. Gibt es auch schon Nokia?
I don't know. Für Nokia haben wir vielleicht hier...
Jetzt seid ihr wieder schon im Rumspielen. Ich muss jetzt kurz noch eine Sache nachschieben. Ich weiß, die Hörer mögen das immer nicht, aber vorhin hatten wir das mit den Displays und so. Und da gab es hier von John Grube auch doll verteilt so ein Display-Shootout zwischen allen dicken Smartphones. Und ich poste mal den Link hier in den V-Chat. Quatsch, V-Chat. Hab ich V-Chat gesagt? In den, wie heißt das Ding? Und da kann man nochmal nachlesen, da sind wirklich die Displays bis aufs kleinste Detail auseinandergenommen. Und ich glaube, das vom iPhone hat insgesamt sogar gewonnen.
Auf displaymartet.com?
Genau. Wenn man es ein bisschen technischer wissen will und so, dann ist das eigentlich ganz gut.
Sieht auch sehr technisch aus, die Seite.
Ja, ein bisschen grün und gelb.
Die sollten wir dann nachher auch nochmal in der Übersicht verlinken.
Wo wir jetzt gerade bei externen Bildschirmen sind. Also erinnert ihr euch vielleicht noch, als ich hier vor zwei Sendungen habe ich hier mal über den externen Mini Display Port, also den iMac als externen Bildschirm für einen anderen Rechner, und dann habe ich während der Sendung hier angeschlossen und dann fiel der Stream aus. Und dem bin ich jetzt mal ein bisschen hinterhergegangen und habe einige beunruhigende Feststellungen gemacht. So was fehlt noch. Genau, das fehlt noch, aber echt. Folgendes, also wenn ich meinen Mini Display Port, nein, wenn ich meinen Laptop, also wenn ich hier meinen Mini Display Port ausgestattetes MacBook oder natürlich auch jeden anderen Computer an meinen iMac anschließe, dann passiert nachvollziehbar Folgendes, ich habe das jetzt mehrere andere Leute testen lassen, wenn jetzt hier jemand zuhört und der auch einen 27 Zoll iMac hat, der dieses Feature hat. Also alle 27 Zoll iMacs haben dieses Feature und ich glaube, die anderen haben das immer noch nicht. Oder haben die neuen 21 Zoller jetzt auch diesen externen Bildschirmmodus? Ich nichts iMacs. Hab ich nichts von gelesen, ich glaube nicht. Also wer so einen 27 Zoll iMac Bildschirm hat, also iMac hat mit Bildschirmen, wissen schon, ich bin durcheinander, wie auch immer. Und man besorgt sich eben so ein Mini Displayport-Kabel, gibt es ja mittlerweile sogar bei Apple zu kaufen, das hat ja auch irgendwie ein Jahr gedauert, und schließt einen anderen Rechner an. Und man spielt am besten gleichzeitig Sound-Up über den eingebauten Audio-Ausgang, also die Buchse hinten. Und zwar ist es, meiner Meinung nach, es ist egal, ob man das im digitalen Modus oder im analogen Modus macht. Also man kann ein optisches Kabel angeschlossen haben oder man kann analoges haben. Plus eine Aufnahme machen über den Audio-Eingang. Also einfach QuickTime-Player starten, Rekord drücken, den Port natürlich vorher auswählen. Und in dem Moment, wo du das Laptop anschließt, oder irgendeinen anderen Rechner anschließt, bricht die Aufnahme ab. Und es gibt absurdeste Audio-Fehler bei der Ausgabe. Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo der iMac als Bildschirm umschaltet, verliert er irgendwie die Kontrolle über seinen Audioport. Und das ist sozusagen im Eimer. Das heißt, man kann diesen Audioport nicht für irgendwas Durchgehendes verwenden. Und jetzt hab ich mich natürlich gefragt, warum ist denn das? Und ich dachte ja zuerst, das wäre irgendwie ein Bug und ich hätte jetzt irgendwie ein kaputtes Gerät oder sowas. Und dann fiel es mir wie Schuppen aus den Haaren. Denn, was Apple nämlich jetzt mit dem iMac 27 Zoll auch tut, ist, dass sie über diesen Mini Display Port einen Audioport anbieten. Den brauch ich auch noch. Den Drama, den hat man jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht gehört auf dem Stream, den Drama-Sound. Könnt ihr mir folgen? Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ich den Bildschirm angeschlossen habe, den iMac angeschlossen habe, taucht tatsächlich auf meinem angeschlossenen Computer ein zusätzlicher Audioport auf.
Das heißt, der laptop schickt per Display-Port auch das Audio zu diesem Riesendisplay?
Könnte er, wenn ich diesen Audioport halt auch auswähle. Das muss ich ja auch erstmal tun. Aber das ist natürlich extrem disruptiv. Also ich schalte quasi meinen Bildschirm um. Und das ist ja auch beim Umschalten. Das ist ja nicht wie so eine Monitor-Umschaltbox, wo ich dann einfach nur was anderes sehe, sondern das Umschalten des Bildschirms beeinflusst erheblich das Audio-Setup beider Computer. Erstens geht es auf meinem iMac alles kaputt. Also der Audioport ist zwar noch da, aber Aufnahmen brechen ab und Ausgabe ist im Eimer. Also er führt das dann fort auszugeben, aber es gibt halt mindestens Fehler. Und Aufnahmen brechen halt komplett ab. Was genau zu dem Stream-Ausfall nämlich geführt hat. Also der war dann einfach tot und ich musste dann das Streaming-Programm stoppen und wieder starten, damit er diesen Port wieder neu öffnet, um dann was zu kriegen, nachdem ich wieder zurückgeschaltet hatte. Aber auch auf dem angeschlossenen Rechner ändert sich ja was. Weil wenn ich nämlich wieder zurückschalte und mir quasi den Inhalt meines iMacs anschaue, dann ist dann der Audioport da wieder, oder ist er weg? Jetzt weiß ich es gerade gar nicht. Auf jeden Fall, es ist ein Drama und ich hatte ja hier überlegt, ob ich mir irgendwie zwei von diesen iMacs nebeneinander stelle und dachte mir dann so ganz pfiffig, naja, dann kann ich ja jeden als externen Bildschirm für den anderen benutzen. Das geht zwar theoretisch auch, aber wenn das halt immer bedeutet, dass wenn ich hin und her schalte, dass mein ganzes Audio-Setup einmal durchgespült wird, ist das für mich irgendwie keine Option mehr. Und bei dem neuen 27-Zoll-Display, also wo kein iMac drin ist, ist das jetzt halt auch so, dass da ein Audioport mit sichtbar ist. Ja genau, Display-Audio, aber über den Mini-Display-Port. Was ich an sich ganz sinnvoll finde. Ja, aber das heißt, das Hin und Her-Schalten bedeutet...
Kann man eigentlich auch bei so einem iMac zwei Displays über Kreuz laufen lassen? Also wenn man da so zwei iMacs verbindet, kann man den Bildschirm enthalten von dem einen und auch den anderen.
Das hab ich nicht selber ausprobiert, aber ich hab das jemanden ausprobieren lassen. Oder ich hab gefragt, ob es schon mal jemand ausprobiert hat. Und der hat es ausprobiert. Und du kannst zwei 27 Zoll iMacs nebeneinander stellen. Und jeder kann für den anderen Bildschirm sein. Und ich glaube sogar, wenn du sie das erste Mal miteinander verbindest, das bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, das wäre mal ganz interessant, falls das jemand schon mal gemacht hat, schalten beide sozusagen auf externen Bildschirm um.
Das ist echt...
Du steckst das Kabel rein.
Ich hielt das eben für einen reinen Witz, aber das geht wirklich.
Du bist in einem externen Monitor-Modus, das heißt, du tauschst sozusagen die Bildschirme aus und beide ruinieren sich wahrscheinlich in dem Moment dann auch ihren Audio-Ausgang. Und Eingang.
Das ist alles wirklich...
Das geht überhaupt nicht. Ja, da kann ich mir auch gleich Flash installieren.
Das ist ja fast so schlimm, wie dass die doppelte Abspiegelschwindigkeit auf dem iPhone gar keine doppelte Abspiegelschwindigkeit ist.
Ja, aber da merkt man auch mal, dass diese ganze Intelligenz, die jetzt in diese Geräte reinkommt, das hat echt Kollateralschäden. Da wünsche ich mir meinen guten alten VGA-Umschalter wieder oben anmachen. Klack, klack, klack, klack, klack, dann können wir halt da gucken und da mal da gucken. Und irgendwie ist einfach die Integrität meines Audio-Setups total wichtig.
Vielleicht kann man das ja mit irgendwelchen Defaults, Writes, Hex... Hex.
Also mir erscheint das ein Bug zu sein, weil mal ehrlich, wenn ich hier umschalte, wieso reißt eine Aufnahme von meinem Audio innen ab? Was hat bitte der Audio innen von dem iMac zu tun mit dem angeschlossenen Computer und der Tatsache, dass der Bildschirm mir jetzt den Inhalt eines anderen Rechners zeigt? Selbst wenn der das Audio liefert, dann ist das ja eigentlich nur eine Durchschaltung zu den Lautsprechern in diesem iMac. Das ist wahrscheinlich überhaupt der Grund. Dadurch, dass ich den anschließe und er sozusagen eine Verbindung zu diesem Lautsprecher machen muss, kappt er, aber das hat doch damit auch alles gar nichts zu tun.
Alles ganz furchtbar.
Steve, bitte, es hat zu enden.
Aber Tim kann sich auch wirklich so über Themen, die sonst kein Interesse haben, aufregen.
Das ist für mich total essenziell super mega wichtig hier. Immer dieser Audio-Scheiß. Das nervt mich mindestens genauso wie dieser Scheiß-Audio-Echo-Bug, der in diesem Powerbook irgendwie monatelang drin war. Wo sich das Ding ganze Zeit wiederholt hat.
Aber ich hab jetzt gerade rausger... Dieses Air-Display, das muss ich natürlich auch nochmal... Wenn man da Windows 7 jetzt drauf macht und das dann so fern bedient... Dann ist ja das iPad so ein Slate-PC. Dann kann man ja mal ausprobieren, wie gut das eigentlich funktioniert.
Das kann so HP empfehlen. Haben sie eine technische Lösung, die auch funktioniert.
HP hat jetzt versehentlich das erste Android-Gerät ausgeliefert. Die haben Drucker ausgeliefert mit abnehmbarem Touch-Display. Und dieses abnehmbare Touch-Display an dem Drucker ist ein Android-Gerät.
Ist das vielleicht endlich der Konkurrent für den iPod Touch? Kann sogar schon drucken.
Das wollte ich auch noch zum iPad erzählen.
Ah!
Das ist zu schwer. Aber da gab es einen coolen Tweet zu, da meinte irgendjemand, das ist auch gar nicht schlimm, dass es keinen Porn für das iPad gibt, weil es eh zu schwer ist, um es in einer Hand zu halten.
Kommt, den haben wir sogar schon mit den 11 Touch-Flächen gemacht.
Ich bin halt neu hier als iPad.
Aber das stimmt, das ist wirklich ein Problem. Ich wollte dafür eigentlich noch was sagen.
Porn auf dem iPad ist echt ein Problem.
Seitdem dieses iOS 4.2 existiert, existiert das Beta und so weiter. Wir haben das ja eigentlich gar nicht. Aber sagen wir mal, ich habe davon Wind bekommen, wie das ist, wenn man das benutzt. Und da stellt man dann fest, dass dieses iPad einem dann doch auf einmal extrem ans Herz wächst. Also es wird auf einmal zum benutzbaren Gerät. Und wie du auch schon sagst, es gibt so bestimmte Dinge, die mache ich dann schon lieber mit dem iPad. Aber was halt wirklich kacke ist, ist so Halten in merkwürdigen, was weiß ich, im Bett oder so. Es geht eigentlich nur diese Position, die Apple in ihrer Werbung vorgibt. Dieses, du legst es auf deinen Schoß und schaust von oben drauf.
Und das ist eigentlich, finde ich...
Auf dem Tisch liegend ist schon doof, weil sie rumkippelt. Die sollten das neue iPad so machen wie das iPhone 4.
Das werden sie auch tun.
Aber genau das finde ich eigentlich schade, weil das ist ja genau das Versprechen gewesen. In diesen Positionen, wo der Computer zu unhandlich ist und du dich immer verrenken musst und so. Dadurch, dass es so schwer ist, liegst du da halt auch nicht so entspannt im Bett rum und so.
Also ich leg das im Bett einfach, ich leg mich dann auf die Seite, leg das Ding daneben und beginne das so. Und hab ja dann auch diese Hülle. Aber die Hülle macht echt viel Sinn. Also die Hülle macht so scheiße wie dieses Neoprene-Link von Apple und so total überteuert. Aber ich kenn bisher nichts, was von praktisch gesehen auch so wahr kommt.
Das ist doch viel zu wankig, man kann da gar nicht mehr ordentlich touchen, wenn es da drauf steht, oder?
Ich muss ja halt ein bisschen vorsichtiger sein.
Aber das würde mir schon echt viel helfen, diese Hülle, glaube ich. Ich muss jetzt ja das iPad wieder der Firma übergeben. Deswegen, also ich warte jetzt eh auf das neue, leichtere, doppelt aufgelöste, nicht kippelnde iPad.
Mit Porn-Unterstützung. Ja, mit Porn-Ständer.
Und was halt auch tatsächlich auffällt, also hier meine Freundin vor allen Dingen, dass es schon nervig ist, dass es da kein Flash gibt manchmal. Weil viele Videos und so, zum Beispiel South Park, gibt es ja im Netz. Alle Folgen und so. Ich gucke ja gerade South Park ganz viel. Und dann dachte ich mir, boah geil, die haben ja bestimmt auch einen HTML5-Viewer. Nee, haben sie nicht, Flash Only.
Tim guckt gerade so, als ob er Huckel direkt rausschmeißt oder ob er ihm vorher noch den Schädel einschlägt.
Ich schreib dir eine Mail, natürlich. Aber es fällt einem dann doch mal auf, wenn man so... Ich war halt einen Tag lang dann auch krank und hab den ganzen Tag so irgendwie gechillt und mit dem iPad rumgesoffen. Da stößt man halt schon auf viele Stellen. Es ist natürlich total cool, weil man viele Werbungen nicht sieht und diesen ganzen Bling-Bling-Scheiß und so weiter. Der bleibt halt weg, wie Click to Flash, bloß ohne Klick. Und das trägt bestimmt auch dazu bei, dass es alles total superschnell und so ist. Aber manchmal so eine Folge South Park. Aber eigentlich natürlich vollkommen richtig. Die sollten natürlich HTML5 anbieten und so. Aber mir ist es halt einfach nur aufgefallen, dass es wirklich dann noch einige Stellen gibt, die...
Ja, ja, das ist schon noch ordentlich was.
Aber sag mal, du als alter Android-Fuchs...
Fuchs, ja.
Du hast doch bestimmt jetzt irgendwie so Geräte mit Flash drauf und so, oder?
Also ich hatte mal dieses Nexus One halt für ein bisschen mit Flash drauf. Du hattest mal dieses, ne? Ich hab mir mal Nexus One ausgeliehen für eine gewisse Zeit lang und hab da Android 2.2 drauf installiert, was damals noch ganz, ganz frisch rauskam. Und dafür gab's dann auch Flash und das hab ich dann auch laufen lassen. Und das war total scheiße. Also es ist genauso.
Also hastest du denn wenigstens so ein paar Einheiten Content, die du damit konsumieren konntest?
Nein, ich hab wirklich keinen sinnvollen Anwendungsfall dafür gefunden. Also vielleicht hätte ich tatsächlich mal auf diese Southpark-Seite gehen sollen.
Wahrscheinlich hat's geruckelt.
Aber so diese ganzen Anwendungsfälle, wie man sie... Also es gab so irgendwo so eine Adobe Demo-Seite, wo dann so dreieinhalb Demo-Applikationen waren, die dann aber auch eigentlich hinreichend langweilig waren. Und irgendwann hab ich es dann mal geschafft, den YouTube-Player, also ich meine, wenn man auf YouTube geht, dann wird man auch weitergeleitet, mittlerweile auf die HTML5-optimierte Variante. Und dann hab ich es geschafft, den YouTube-Player zu sehen, dann bist du irgendwann im Fullscreen-Modus und kommst nicht mehr richtig raus oder du triffst diesen kleinen Playbutton nicht richtig, weil der halt viel zu klein ist, um mit dem Finger getouched zu werden, das ist wirklich ganz furchtbar. Also nimm dieses Air-Display hier, mach damit einen YouTube-Player auf und probier damit, irgendwas Sinnvolles zu machen. Es wird ja einfach nicht gelingen, weil das ist Flash, das heißt jetzt nicht, dass man das nicht alles nachrüsten könnte, aber die 99% dieser Flash-Anwendungen da draußen sind einfach nicht für Touch gemacht. Und da wird sich auch nichts mehr dran ändern. Da kann die Technologie noch was sein. Ich meine, da könnte Apple auch damit werben, wir haben ja auch Coco da drauf und damit sind ja auch automatisch alle Programme drüber. Nee, sind sie natürlich nicht. Ich fand also, ja, also für Videokontent, ich find's ein bisschen albern, dass so viele Video-Webseiten es offensichtlich noch nicht schaffen, da was zu hinterlegen. Alternative, aber ansonsten hab ich da nicht viel vermisst. Außer die ganzen Werbebande natürlich.
Ja, ich eigentlich, wie gesagt, hauptsächlich South Park. Weil YouTube wie Meo und so, die sind ja eh schon am Start.
Ja, das hätt ich, also John Stewart, also The Daily Show hätt ich gern mal drauf geguckt.
Stimmt, genau, das wollt ich auch gucken. Das gab's auch nicht, genau.
Also es gibt schon ein paar Sachen, die gibt's nicht.
Aber da war ich sowieso überrascht, dass BitTorrent an der Stelle total extrem performt. Weil diese Daily Show und Colbert Report, die kriegste da im Flash Player total ätzend langsam. Und wenn du die im Torrent klickst, sind die irgendwie instant da. Was war denn da noch mit dieser Daily Show und so?
Da gibt's noch eine ganz fiese Mac-Applikation, mit der du das wunderbar automatisieren kannst. TV-Shows?
Nee, noch nicht.
So ein ganz fieses kleines Tool, was sich auf dein Mac auch als Demon installiert. Da klickst du dann einmal im User-Interface, welche Serien du so gerne hättest. Und er organisiert dir sozusagen automatisch die neuen Folgen und wirft gleich deinen Beton-Client an. Das ist so richtig böse.
Warte, ich wollte noch mal kurz, bevor wir hier in die Toll-In-Welt abtauchen. Es gab da jetzt die letzten Folgen immer hier so Video-Converter, Transcoding, Muxer und so weiter, Ups. Und ich habe jetzt ein paar davon probiert. Und ich muss ja sagen, ich habe mit keinem dieser Tools so ein befriedigendes Erlebnis bei einem Video-Pfeil, also bei einem speziellen Video-Pfeil, erzielen können. In den Kommentaren war ja so ein schickes Tool mal empfohlen worden. Permuter heißt das. Das sieht total schick aus. Oder Permute, ja. Und kommt mit einem totalen Versprechen nachher, wir machen alles außer Tiernahrung. Aber das hat irgendwie überhaupt nicht funktioniert bei mir. Das hat noch gar kein Pfeil produziert, was man verwenden konnte. Dieses Supler hattest du ja zuletzt empfohlen, ne?
Da hatte ich bis dahin auch keine Probleme, aber mittlerweile auch teilweise mit manchen MKVs ist das nicht die Ergebnisse, die ich gerne hätte.
Also er kann halt wirklich nur den Container umpacken, wenn da aber irgendwelche Features drin benutzt, die Apple nicht kann, dann geht's halt nicht. Weil dann müsste er doch neue transkoden.
Du meinst jetzt Features in dem H264 selbst? Ja, das ist natürlich die Profilgeschichte, ist nochmal eine andere Frage.
Aber die MKVs, die du da kriegst, das ist ja alles x264.
Ja, aber da gibt's halt Features drin, die kann Apple halt nicht.
Das H264 ist ja nur das Encoding Framework und dann gibt's noch verschiedene Profiles. Baseline-Profile, Advanced-Profile. Und mit 10.6 ist vieles besser geworden. Also seit 10.6 kann QuickTime schon sehr viel mehr als es vorher konnte. Aber es ist eben auch unklar, was eigentlich genau und was nicht. Es macht dann halt einfach auf und sagt, kann ich nicht. Und das ist halt ein Problem. Und auch die iOS-Devices sind immer besser geworden. Also das ursprüngliche iPhone konnte ja nur... Der ursprüngliche Video-iPod, der konnte halt so 640x, also erst nur 320x240, dann 640x480 nach dem Software-Update. Und über die Zeit haben sie halt, ich glaube das aktuelle iPhone kann sogar... 720p. Nein, kann sogar 1080p.
iPad oder iPhone? Nee, 27.
Du kannst da einen 1080p-Film drauflegen und der ist in der Lage, das sogar noch auszugeben.
Aber bestimmt nicht hier 80, 20 Gigabyte-Files.
1080p, das will ich ja sehen.
Also auf dem Bildschirm wird es keinen Unterschied machen.
Das ist klar, aber es würde mir reichen, wenn es abspielen könnte, weil dann könnte man halt so rappen und ist egal, auf welchem Device man sich es angucken will, es geht halt. Aber ich habe bisher 27p probiert und das geht.
Also 1080p wird mich jetzt auch wundern, weil das Apple TV, was ja im Wesentlichen den gleichen Prozessor hat, das kann ja auch keinen 1080p abspielen.
Ich habe nicht bestätigt, ob das geht oder nicht. Also laut Apple kriegst du, wenn du eine Filme leist, sie in 27p. Aber was dieses Gerät wirklich abspielen kann, das warten wir mal ab. Ich habe eine Versandbestätigung bekommen.
Aber das heißt, noch mal zu diesen Videotools kurz, das heißt, keins von den Tools, was jetzt wieder so... Also was ist jetzt dein aktueller Favorit?
Also ich hab mit Zappler, also wir müssen noch mal kurz sagen, was eigentlich das Ziel war. Das Ziel war, MKVs in MPEG-4-Container zu bringen, ohne den H264-Teil zu re-encoden.
Das heißt, eigentlich ist das nur das File, wird neu abgespeichert, aber es wird nicht umgerechnet.
Tracks werden extrahiert und in einen anderen Container gebracht.
CPU-Power braucht man eigentlich gar nicht, man braucht nur Platten-Power.
Im Sapler muss man einfach den Track einmal kopieren und das war's. Aber man schreibt ihn mehr oder weniger, es ist und muss nicht jeden Pixel nehmen und decoden und encoden und Foo machen. Da ist Handbrake immer noch das beste Tool, seitdem die nicht nur DVDs, sondern beliebige Movies als Input nehmen können. Das rockt auf allen Prozessoren und auf allen Chores.
Das funktioniert echt gut.
Das ist wirklich perfekt, aber ich fände es schon schöner. Dieses MKV-Tools war das erste, auf das ich gestoßen bin, was es überhaupt gemacht hat. Zu dem Zeitpunkt, als ich darüber berichtet habe, lief es super. Danach hatte ich Probleme. Mit Zappler war es genauso. Und jetzt muss man halt mal schauen, wie sich das entwickelt. Zappler ist open source, vielleicht tut sich da noch was.
Ich wollte ja auch zu dem Thema, wo wir gerade sind, bei diesem Video mal kürzlich ein Video, mal ein HTML5 hochschieben und dachte mir, mit QuickTime alles aufgenommen, ging ja easy auf dem Mac. Dann dachte ich mir, guckst du mal im Firefox und guckst du mal auf ein Google-Handy und so weiter. Dann dachte ich mir, guckst du mal, wie man jetzt so ein WebM-Video macht und ein OGV-Video. Und dann habe ich auf dem Mac echt das nicht geschafft, irgendwie ein Video dahin zu batzeln, was irgendwie funktioniert hat. Bei dem OGV habe ich dann rausgefunden, dass mein Web-Server noch den richtigen Mime-Type kennenlernen musste, für OGV, damit er das auch richtig ausliefert.
Für MPEG-4 wahrscheinlich auch, oder?
Ja, das hatte ich schon scheinbar. Also OGV und MP4 für die Apple-Welt habe ich dann hingekriegt, aber WebM war auf dem Mac anscheinend noch komplett unmöglich. Also es gibt halt noch keine QuickTime-Components dafür. Es gibt halt von dieser WebM Group irgendwie einen Alpha-Release 0.0.2 von August oder so und das funktioniert halt nicht. Also du installierst und es ist halt nicht da im QuickTime und so, nicht verfügbar und kann nichts abspielen und nichts exportieren. Dann kannst du dir das halt noch selber bauen, aber das hat auch nicht so auf Anhieb funktioniert. Und wenn da irgendwelche Hörer noch einen schlauen Tipp haben, weil mit Handbrake geht es ja auch nicht. Handbrake macht ja glaube ich nur MPEG-4 und MKV-Container. Also wenn es da bei der Werten-Hörer-Schaft irgendwelche Tipps gibt, wie man auf dem Mac so eine WebM-Tool-Chain ans Laufen kriegt mit wenig Schmerz, da wäre ich immer...
Wahrscheinlich so FFMPEG und auf der Kommandozeile, oder?
Ja, aber es ist so, ja, wahrscheinlich FFMPEG. Aber es gab halt jedenfalls keins, auch dieses Permute oder so hat halt kein Tool das geschafft, so ein Pfeil, da zu produzieren, was auch wieder abspielbar war. Also ich hab's zumindest nicht geschafft. Also FIFA hat ja mit seinem... Es gibt doch dieses Command Line-Tool MP4 Creator, das ist bis seitdem schon mal begegnet. Das benutzt der glaube ich der FIFA, um irgendwie seine ganzen komischen Videos und so.
MP4 Box?
Ich glaube MP4 Creator.
Da gibt's noch MP4 V2, da gibt's so einige Sachen. Ich hab nur MP4 V2 verwendet, aber nicht um Videos zu... Meinst du, N-Koden?
Na du hast ein Video und willst das jetzt in WebM zum Beispiel auch nochmal haben.
Also Re-N-Koden, ja.
Und so was. Genau, MP4 Creator gibt's auch als Tool. Na egal, also so eine Make-Tool-Chain dafür wär auch nicht schlecht, weil im Prinzip ist ja dann schon cool, wenn man irgendwelche Videos veröffentlichen will und das nicht bei YouTube und Vimeo hosten will, sondern vielleicht selber auf dem Server haben will mit so einem HTML5-Player, dass natürlich dann auch möglichst alle das sehen können, weil ich wollte halt hier irgendwie so einen kleinen Hocker-Show-Off machen und irgendwie dachte mir, hey, geil, mach ich jetzt schnell mit QuickTime und meiner Bild-In... Eyesight-Kamera. So, hab ich hier so runtergemacht, Display runtergemacht und dann so aufgenommen, dann hochgeschoben und ging sofort und dann irgendwie gleich ist der Kollege mit dem Linux gesagt, oh, geht nicht. Ja, und dann fiel mir erstmal auf, dass...
Die keinen QuickTime haben.
Nee, was halt YouTube und Vimeo einem dann sozusagen abnimmt.
Dieses ganze Video-Konvertieren ist die Hölle. Also ich glaube, ich hab...
Aber ich will es halt... Also ich bin ja immer so ein Freund von selber hosten und so mal selber so ein Video-hosten, dass alle das im Web-Browse abspielen können, ist halt echt...
Ja, aber da brauchst du erstmal einen Videoplayer drum herum, der sich um das ganze Zeug kümmert. Du brauchst halt für jeden Scheiß-Track musst du dich drum kümmern. Und dann musst du auch die Bandbreite wirklich schaffen, dass das der auch größeren Anlauf gewechselt ist.
Also in dem Moment hab ich dann echt mal YouTube und Vimeo nochmal auf eine andere Art und Weise schätzen gedacht.
Da kannst du ja wirklich quasi alles reinschmeißen und irgendwie spielen die das schon ab. Das ist eigentlich echt hardcore, was die da auf die Reihe kriegen.
Und die schaffen es dann auch mit HTML finden.
Also ich hab's ja mal eine Zeit lang probiert, hier irgendwie halbwegs automatisiert. Tony Mahoney-Videos, falls ihr euch noch an den erinnern könnt, dass der von seiner Kamera die Videos zu uns auf den Server lädt und das dann automatisch, also da muss man bei Spreelik einen Vorspann und einen Abspann hinten dran geschnitten wird und das Ganze dann in ein paar iPod-tauglichen Format und in den diversen MPEG-4 und FLV Formaten abgespeichert wird. Ich bin da so gnadenlos dran gescheitert. Also das Konvertieren hätte noch geklappt, aber so dieses MPEG-2-Video, was er da hochgeladen hat, was von seiner Kamera kam, was man dann erstmal noch demuxen musste, also dieses Audio- und Videostream irgendwie aufeinander miteinander verknüppelt, das war so furchtbar, das will man echt nicht machen müssen. Das war, YouTube ist schon Dufte.
So, also MPEG-4 Creator ist, wie ich gerade feststelle, ich habe es das erste Mal gesehen, das ist von Cisco, von der MPEG-4 IP-Suite ist das ein Teil und gibt es im Source, kann man sich aus dem Subversion runterladen, für Windows haben sie 32-Bit-Binaries. Hab jetzt bei Mac-Ports erstmal keinen Port gefunden, aber vielleicht gibt es das ja irgendwie. MP4-Creator, also nicht... mp4creator.sourceforce.net, aber vielleicht... Genau, Brew habe ich jetzt noch nicht geguckt.
Warte, ich gucke.
Wie macht man das bei Brew? Einfach Brew Search auch?
Ja, aber gibt es nicht. Aber wenn das in einer Suite ist, dann Suite, wie auch immer.
Genau, da gibt es MP4-Box und MP4-V2, das ist nämlich...
So, und jetzt hattest du gesagt, gibt es irgendwie tolle Tools zum Serienrippen, wie hieß das nochmal?
TV-Show, nicht zum Rippen. Zum automatisiert...
Konsumieren.
Ich hab da unterschiedliche Ergebnisse mit erzielt. Manches holt er andere Sachen, meint er zwar zu haben, aber kriegt über Monate nichts aktualisiert. Der zapft irgendwelche ominösen RSS-Feeds, aus denen tausendfalls rausfallen kann.
Die zwischendurch weggeklagt werden.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Das ist auch so ein Tool, mit dem will man sich gar nicht so sehr beschäftigen. Ich war schon erstaunt, dass es das überhaupt gab.
Und dann hatten wir irgendwie noch einen Thementhread, den wir irgendwie noch suspended haben. Dennis, erzähl mal. Irgendwas war doch noch.
Ja, ja.
Bei diesem Video, in diesem ganzen Video, in dieser Videomélange und dem Flash und dem iPad und dem...
Den Display-Link hab ich doch schon gepostet.
Und dem Feld in Germany, also dem Thema Feld in Germany fällt noch was ein.
Das setzt ja ganz weit zurück.
Habt ihr mal davon gehört, dass irgendwie beim Axel Springer-Verlag flächendeckend Macintoshes angewendet werden sollen? Das war doch mal die Big News, ne? Ich hab da so ein Tidbit gesteckt bekommen von irgendwie einem Insider. Weißt du, was die damit machen, mit dem Macs? Ernsthaft? Migration fand nicht statt. Ja, weil die haben da irgendwie so ein IT-Department, die einfach sagen, so Macs kommen uns nicht ins Haus. Weil das wurde einfach mal vom Chef ja mal so bekannt gegeben und so. Wir sind jetzt irgendwie alle ganz hip und machen jetzt hier Apple. Weil wir wollen ja auch alle iPhones haben und so. Und wo kommen wir denn da hin? Aber eigentlich, außer jetzt so den klassischen Grafikabteilungen, haben sie jetzt wahrscheinlich alle ihre iMacs auf den Tisch und fahren da irgendwie Windows. Falls da irgendeiner der Hörer noch ein bisschen mehr Einblick hat, als ich jetzt meine zu haben, dann wären wir da über interessante Weise auch dankbar.
Du meinst, der Mac-Hardware-Anteil da draußen ist... Warum ist meine Stimme so komisch? Du hast so schön an den Regeln gespielt.
Deine Stimme ist super.
Na gut, der Mac-Hardware-Anteil da draußen ist noch viel höher als das, was die so über ihre Webseitenklickies so feststellen. Weil, sagen wir mal, Webseitenklickies sind so 5% Macs. Und in Wirklichkeit sind es aber 10% Macs, die aber Windows fahren.
Oder Linux. Mac war ja nochmal Linux-Hardware of the Year 2004 oder 2005 oder so.
Also ich würde eher mal sagen, dass das dann der Anteil... Weißt du, dass dann eher der Hackintosh-Anteil noch deutlich höher ist von irgendwelchen eigentlichen...
Ja, aber ich benutze auch gerade einen.
Einen Hackintosh?
Ja, das hab ich mir gebraucht von einem Kumpel. Weil ich brauchte irgendwie remote einen Rechner, der per SSH erreichbar ist und USB hat und den ich dann halt ans Display anschließe, damit ich mit meinem Rechner immer zum Display latschen muss, um da was zu machen und dann wieder zum Tisch zu latschen und weiter zu koden. Jetzt hab ich den Rechner da ans Display geklatscht, lasse ihn da so stehen und kann das alles von remote machen.
Wenn es einmal läuft, ist das ja auch ganz okay.
Geht dann halt kein Ton oder WLAN halt nicht?
Doch, WLAN geht. Grafik ist beschleunigt, also es war alles super cool.
Habt ihr gehört, dass neuer Apple Store aufgemacht hat?
In Dresden oder wo?
Chemnitz, Cottbus, Halle.
Alles außer Berlin.
Castrop-Rauxel.
Ja, aber da ist ja klar.
Wo ist denn Oberhausen?
In Oberhausen gibt es halt nicht viel.
Wo ist denn der Shit?
In Rheinland, NRW.
Ach da.
Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Da drinnen hier, bei Duisburg und Mühlheim an der Ruhr.
Und es besteht hauptsächlich aus einem riesen Einkaufszentrum.
Verstehe.
Oberhausen jetzt.
Oberhausen ist ein Einkaufszentrum.
Ja, ein riesiges, genau.
Ach so, und Zentro heißt das sozusagen nur, weil es die Stadtmitte ist oder was?
Ja und die Häuser, die dann ringsrum sind, das sind alles nur die bediensteten, sozusagen dieser Mega-Mall. Die Deko.
Ich dachte das ganze Ruhrgebiet wäre eigentlich nur...
Dann zoom mal weiter ran, schalten wir auf Satellite um.
Ja, schalten wir auf Satellite.
Genau, wir wollen hier Live-Coverage. On my desk, within the hour.
Was? Na ja, dieses Zentro, wo ist denn das hier?
Do we have Satellite? Jetzt zoom doch mal ran hier.
Wohin denn? Was denn?
Satellite.
Jetzt kommt wieder hier diese blöde Maus.
Biep, biep, kleiner Satellit.
Was jetzt? Mach doch mal Satellit.
Was wollt ihr denn überhaupt?
Wir wollen den Mall sehen.
Wir wollen das Einkaufszentrum in Oberhausen sehen.
Die haben sogar eine Centro Allee.
Ich sehe die Mall hier. Die Mall heißt Centro.
Und das ist der Lego Brand Store direkt ganz...
Ach echt?
Und jetzt zoom mal ran mit deiner Maus.
Entspann dich. Da.
Ist ganz schön verpixelt.
Ist halt noch nicht von Apple freigegeben, ne?
So.
Und Apple gehört dem Ding in der Mitte, ne?
Das große Kreuz. Die anderen Läden wurden alle auf den Parkplatz verbannt. Na, ich weiß nicht, wo die da sind, aber ich meine, es ist unspektakulär. Ist halt so ein Apple Store.
Ja, wie soll ich denn auch da hinkommen, Jungs? Friedrichstraße, oder wie Timme schon seit Jahren sagt, Kuhgamm.
Ist das nicht geil, die bauen jetzt überall dahin, wo es einfach wirklich von Berlin scheiße weit weg ist. Nach Dresden fährst du mit dem Auto zwei Stunden.
Hamburg eineinhalb.
Mit dem Zug fährst du drei Stunden.
Hamburg.
Friedrichstraße.
Ja, Hamburg-Alzerlof. Das ist dann nochmal da oben. Da musst du dann nochmal eine halbe Stunde mit der S-Bahn fahren, bis du wirklich da bist. Ich meine, sie bauen jetzt irgendwie am Jungfernstieg, wie es aussieht, aber es sieht wohl so aus, dass Dresden da, also die hibern halt schon. Also suchen halt jetzt Mitarbeiter.
Weißt du, was haben die in Berlin vor? Aber am Kuhdamm, da bauen sie ja so ein Hochhaus jetzt gerade, oder?
Entweder finden die keinen Platz, oder Berlin ist ihnen zu arm.
Wahrscheinlich.
Oder all of the above. Aber am Kuhdamm, also da in der Gedächtnis-Kirche, bauen sie ja so ein Hochhaus.
Zu seiner neuen Hauptstadt Germania um.
Leute, einer.
Psst. Steve baut Berlin dann zur Hauptstadt Germania um.
Geil, das ist doch wirklich die Idee. Weil wir hauen einfach das Kanzleramt irgendwie weg und bauen einfach Germania als Apple Store neu auf. Weißt du, so eine komplette Regierungsvote wird einfach mit so einer riesigen Glaskuppe, ja, so in Original Hitler der Menschen.
Ein 800 Meter hoher Glaskontainer mit einem riesen Apple-Logo dran. Stimmt, wahrscheinlich kaufen die einfach die Tempelhofer Flughaff-Flecht auf. Da kommt dann so ein riesen Apples-Store hin.
Oder da, wo am Kuhdamm, wo sie das Riesenrad hinbauen wollten.
Die haben nur, egal, diese Riesenradfirmen, das war ja auch so ein großer Spaß.
Naja, wir müssen, also wir Berliner hier, ihr hört wahrscheinlich von überall zu, wir Berliner sind am Darben, ja, nach einer Kathedrale.
Ja, vor allem diese iPhone-Headsets, die gehen ja so schnell kaputt. Ja, ich hab zwei getauscht. Ich hab jetzt schon wieder zwei kaputte. Nee, entschuldigung, ich hab einen kaputtest. Und jetzt hab ich sozusagen nur noch einen heilen. Und ich hab halt immer gerne mindestens einen oder zwei heile Spare, damit ich einfach die Zeit bis das nächste Mal in der Stadt vorbeikomme, wo ein Apple Store ist.
Gibt's nicht irgendwie so höherwertige Headsets im Zubehörmarkt?
Die gehen alle schnell kaputt.
Genau, das ist das Problem. Das ist das kleine Fricke-Kabel-Scheiße, die haben wir noch nie gut.
Ja, ich hab auch so einen Teil. Ich hab dieses Nokia-Teil, das ist so ein bisschen so. Das geht so ein bisschen, toll ist es nicht. Und ich überleg schon die ganze Zeit, ob ich mir dieses Sennheiser-Dinger hole. Weil die sind wohl toll.
So diese Immun-Linsterlinks, weil die auch kaputtgehen.
Die gehen genauso schnell kaputt, das ist das Problem.
Es gibt auch das Gerücht, dass die Latenz bei denen geringer ist. Mit den Nokia-Headsets kann ich nicht Audio schneiden. Das hab ich heute wieder im Zug probiert. Das dauert einfach zu lange. Du machst da irgendwie Play und so. Und dann hast du immer noch so eine Latenz. Das heißt, bis du eine Stelle hörst, ist eigentlich das Programm schon wieder dran vorbei gescrollt. Und das ist irgendwie nicht so schön. Und das soll bei den Sennheisern weniger sein. Ich kann mir das bloß eigentlich gar nicht so recht vorstellen. Weil ich dachte, diese Latenz kommt durch die eigentliche Ausstrahlung bei Bluetooth. Und nicht so sehr dadurch, dass das Headset selber noch irgendwie buffert.
Nee, nee, das ist 60 in den Nokia-Kopfhörern.
Bitte?
Nein, nein, Witz. Aber gibt's denn eigentlich mittlerweile mal...
Amigo!
Gibt's denn eigentlich mal mittlerweile Bluetooth-Headsets, bei denen man mehrere Quellen angeben kann? Also, dass ich die gleichzeitig mit meinem iPhone und meinem Desktop verbunden haben kann? Nee, damit ich da nicht irgendwie umschalten muss oder weiß ja toll was oder hier ist mein neuer Pärn oder so.
Bluetooth ist wie mit Druckern. Also da gibt's auch immer so die tollsten Versprechungen, wir lösen jetzt dieses Kabelproblem und so weiter und wat ist nisch des?
Manchmal, manchmal braucht man halt einfach Kabel. Aber das ist auch das Schöne an diesen Sennheiser-Dingern, die haben halt auch noch unsere Kabeloptionen. Also sie haben sowohl Bluetooth, aber es gibt ja auch Momente, wo du das nicht haben willst, also einerseits wegen der Relatanz, andererseits im Flugzeug, da möchtest du dann halt unter Umständen Kabel haben.
Im Flugzeug möchtest du Kabel haben?
Ja, wenn du im Flugzeug mit einem Bluetooth-Headset sitzt, dann hast du halt schnell mal das Servicepersonal in deiner Seite, die dich darauf hinweist, dass du halt hier gerade 2,4 Gigahertz funkst.
Die messen das doch nicht wirklich.
Was heißt, die messen das nicht? Die wissen einfach, dass das ein Wireless-Kopfhörer ist.
Da musst du einfach ein Kabel dranhängen. Einfach so eine Schnur dranbinden.
Na ja, gut, muss er halt erst machen. Aber leuchtet blau.
Im Gegensatz zur deutschen Bahn haben die ja so ein Flugzeug richtig Checkung, ja? Von neuesten Trends.
Nein, haben sie nicht.
In der Bahn ist das egal, ob du Blutfluss machst oder nicht.
Komischerweise.
Also ich hab ja irgendwann mal gelesen, dass man spät.
Ich bin ja heute zum ersten Mal seit gefühlten zwei Jahren wieder auf der Deutsche Bahn gefahren und es hat geklappt.
Das hat bei mir auch geklappt. Ich mein, ich musste dann in den Spandau aussteigen, weil Kinder auf der Strecke waren, aber da können sie ja nichts führen. Kinder auf der Strecke, hieß es.
Aber was ja ein Fail ist, ist ja hier T-Mobile-Opfer, ne? Krass. Da gibt's ja jetzt, hab ich gelesen, gibt's in ICE. Skip, skip, skip. Gibt's T-Mobile-Hotspots, ne?
Krass.
Klick ich, ist da, ist da, ist T-Mobile-Hotspot da. Hamburg, Berlin, dachte ich. Und dann kommt da so ein Captive Portal und sagt, es ist nur auf bestimmten Strecken, Köln, Düsseldorf oder Köln, Hannover verfügbar.
Warum machen sie das denn nicht gleich aus? Erstmal einfangen und dann wieder Captive Portal und sagen, nee danke, damit sie erzählen können, ob es sich lohnt, ja?
Keine Ahnung, weil ich als T-Mobile-Opfer hätte da wenigstens kostenlos und so direkt da reingekonnt, aber das ist das 21. Jahrhundert.
Ja, das ist großartig, vor allem du kannst auf dem iPhone, auf diesem Hotspot gar nicht joinen, weil du musst ja da deinen blöden Login eintragen. Diese Zeichenkette, die sie irgendwie aus...
Aber das macht doch Mobile-Buttler für dich, dachte ich.
Der Mobile-Buttler...
Aber der findet den gar nicht, weil der ja nur die Geo, also die fest Eingetragenen kennt und den in der Bahn gar nicht on the fly.
Seit iOS 3 ist ja dieser Extra-Screen, der da so hochkommt. Also ich hab das mit diesem Mobile-Buttler nicht hinbekommen bisher. Wenn da jemand andere Erfahrungen hat... Also ich hab derzeit kein Tool, mit dem man dieses T-Mobile-Hotspot auf dem iPhone automatisch reinentern und irgendwie automatisieren kann.
Aber du hast T-Mobile?
Ich nutze einen T-Mobile-Hotspot-Account. Ich muss ihn nicht selber zahlen, aber ich darf ihn benutzen.
Ja, du könntest auch meinen benutzen, weil so selten wie ich irgendwie mal einen finde, der auch wirklich irgendwie funktioniert und am Internet hängt.
Ja, eigentlich könnte jeder mal so seinen Hotspot-Account einfach in irgendeinen Wiki reinschreiben und dann hätte Deutschland einfach mal endlich mal W-Laden. Das wäre auch nicht blöd.
Stimmt eigentlich.
Naja, oder die Teile, die irgendwie in der Nähe eines T-Mobile-Hotspots sind.
Apropos, hast du ja GSM an?
Nee.
Irgendwas hat dir gerade gechirpt.
Ich hab auch irgendwas gechirpt.
Apropos Telekom, wenn wir schon bei den Telekom-Opfern sind, da gibt es jetzt dieses Gerücht, dass das Telekom-Sperre oder schon die Exklusivität da Ende Oktober vorbei ist.
Ende Oktober schon?
Heißt es denn, dass für das Opfer, das hier links von mir sitzt, heißt es denn, dass du den Monat freischalten kannst oder musst du jetzt noch zwei Jahre oder anderthalb abwarten?
Es ändert sich gar nichts.
Und alle anderen können sich irgendwie anlocken?
Es ändert sich überhaupt nichts.
Wieso nicht?
Weil Vodafone genau den gleichen Scheiß macht wie die Telekom. Meinst du?
Ist doch in allen anderen Ländern auch nicht so gewesen.
Es ist ein Netlock. Also nach der aktuellen Berichtelage wird auch bei Vodafone ein Netlock sein.
Und warum ändert die Telekom denn schon ihre Tarife? Weil die Konkurrenz kommt nur nicht, weil das Anlock kommt.
Jetzt müssen sie halt zweifendlich billiger machen. Glaubst du nicht, dass jetzt zwischen Vodafone und Telekom sowas wie Wettbewerb entsteht?
Ich hoffe.
Das ist doch nicht dein Ernst.
Aber wir haben keine Erwartungen. Wir werden jetzt eigentlich zu keinen von beiden.
Ich finde es enttäuschend, dass O2 nicht mit im Boot ist. Das wär jetzt mal was gewesen.
Woher weißt du denn das?
Boah, weiß ich was.
Nur weil man noch nichts gehört hat.
Also okay, vielleicht wird das noch nachgeliefert, aber bisher... Aber wenn beide da gewesen wären und für Wodafone jetzt das Embargo ablief, da nichts darüber erzählen zu dürfen, dann...
Also wo das offiziell war, haben wir ja noch nichts gesagt, Wodafone.
War doch nicht was, das O2 auch schon, welche Aufsteller irgendwie da hat, die nach einem freien Verkauf aussehen.
Mir war so.
Deswegen ist hier ein Kino-Streu.
Hast du mal gelesen, diese Aufsteller, was da drauf stand?
Naja, ich such grad, ob ich sie noch finde.
Also guck mal, ich bin hier auf der Wodafone-Webseite, da steht es nirgendswo, wir haben bald das iPhone. Und die hätten das, ich glaub, die hätten die Webseite weggenommen und hätten da ein fettes iPhone drauf gemacht, wenn sie es schon ankündigen dürften.
Ja, von Oberhausen. Also übrigens hier, Tim, guck mal. So spektakulär sieht der aus.
Ich bin gerade nicht ganz aktuell hier. Was, wie, wo, was?
So sieht's wunderschön in Oberhausen aus.
Ja, wie so ein Apple Store halt. Okay, alles klar, ich nehme alles zurück.
Im gerade hat jemand im Chat geschrieben, also der vodafone.de Twitter-Account hat getwittert, entgegen aller Gerüchte können wir nicht bestätigen, ob und wann das iPhone bei uns erhältlich sein wird.
Wir dürfen das nicht bestätigen.
Er hat nicht gesagt, nee.
Er hat gesagt, er kann es nicht bestätigen, ob und wann.
Ist doch egal, ob sie das nicht dürfen.
Auf jeden Fall gibt es keine Presseerklärung, wir haben das iPhone und mit anderen Worten, wenn die Sperre für Vodafone noch nicht geendet ist, kann einfach sein, dass O2 besser daran ist, die Klappe zu halten. Also es heißt nicht zwangslang...
Kann sein.
Es könnte natürlich sein, dass sie einfach sagen, okay, wir sind jetzt beim größten Provider, sind wir jahrelang gewesen, jetzt nehmen wir noch den zweitgrößten mit dazu, wäre Apple definitiv zuzutrauen.
Ja, aber dann sinkt auch trotzdem schon mal die Einnahme, die sie von der Telekom bekommen. Also ist nicht mehr ganz so exklusiv.
Weil sie nicht mehr die Exklusivität haben.
Genau, dafür kriegen sie natürlich von Vodafone auch was, aber insgesamt weniger, weil natürlich sich die Anzahl der verkauften Telefone auf zwei aufteilt, auch wenn es insgesamt ein bisschen mehr wird.
Aber es kann natürlich auch sein, dass sie einfach mit... Also mit dem iPad sind sie ja sehr offen umgegangen, das gibt es ja nur mit direkt bei Apple auch mit jeder Karte zu kaufen, oder? Auch Apple Plus, aber auf jeden Fall O2, Telekom, Vodafone. Und würde ja total reichen, wenn sie in Zukunft dann einfach über ihren Apple Store, dass man online hingehen kann und sich da ein iPhone kaufen kann und ge-unlockt ist.
Wäre doch super. Also für mich wäre eigentlich nur wichtig, dass ja nächstes Jahr das iPhone 5 rauskommt, dass ich nicht wieder nach irgendwie Italien muss oder jemand anders für mich, sondern dass ich in den Store gehen kann, kann sagen, hier, gib her, ich finde wieder einen, der mein iPhone 4 abnimmt und alles ist happy. Da kann ich mir auch schon vorbestellen und gleich am ersten Tag irgendwie das kriegen.
Genau, so wie alle Telekom-Kunden das sofort am ersten Tag gekriegt haben, die es vorbestellt haben, ihr iPhone 4.
Ja, unser Opfer hier, wann hast du deins bekommen? Richtig früh. Opfer sind hält früh dran, ist doch klar.
Du kannst auch so so Läden wie 3G-Store-Rennen, die dir das gerne verkaufen.
Das kostet ja auch dementsprechend.
Naja, extra Mark, extra Fleisch.
Aber was natürlich vielleicht mal eine Erwähnung wert ist, dieses Vorgehen, dass man sein iPhone mittlerweile auch, egal wo es in Europa gekauft ist, auch in Deutschland reparieren lassen kann, was ja jetzt so eine Zeit lang unter der Hand funktioniert hat. Ist jetzt offiziell hier. Offiziell bestätigt. Also das geht ja ganz problemlos jetzt. Und ich hatte ja hier mit meinem iPhone, mit meinem 3GS, das habe ich ja auch reparieren lassen.
Nicht nur in Europa.
Hat ganz hervorragend funktioniert. Also ich glaube, für Europa haben sie es offiziell bestätigt auf jeden Fall.
Aber inoffiziell habe ich die Bestätigung auch in Kanada bekommen. Ich habe mein iPhone in Kanada reparieren lassen.
Nee, aber das ist das Deutsche. Also in Deutschland kannst du aus ganz Europa die iPhones reparieren lassen. Offiziell? Offiziell. Also kannst du ein italienisches iPhone ganz offiziell jetzt bei Apple einschicken. In Deutschland. Und das wird ja repariert werden.
Ja, und du kannst auch in Kanada ganz offiziell in den Apple Store einreden.
Ja, aber sie haben es nicht offiziell gesagt. Sie haben gesagt, wir nehmen auch kanadische iPhones, können auch in Deutschland repariert werden. Den Weg haben sie nicht gesagt.
Kanadische iPhones in Deutschland repariert.
Also du wirst wahrscheinlich keine Probleme mit haben, aber offiziell haben sie nur gesagt Europa.
Ja, okay, wie auch immer. Also ich hab das schon durchaus als offiziell.
Nee, jetzt haben sie immer ganz offiziell, so richtig offiziell gesagt, so hallo, wie machen wir das?
Wir haben hier gerade so tolle neue Features hier auf unseren V-Remotes. Und die Taste ist gut, oder? Da vibrieren alle V-Modes, wenn man eine Taste drückt.
Das heißt Up The Shut Fuck, You Must.
Ich glaub, wir haben Sendungstitel.
Das ist schon der zweite.
Das war der erste. Schon wieder failed, hatten wir im letzten Titel schon.
Zu viel Fail ist nicht gut.
Genau.
Aber vielleicht ist das ja ein Hinweis drauf, dass man jetzt bei, auf der O2-Webseite, Macbook ganz fett auf der Startseite ist. Apple schon mal auf der Startseite.
Ich hab mir letztens ja auch ein neues T-Shirt gekauft. Das war ähnlich schön. Ist mir egal, lass ich jetzt einfach so am Standard drauf.
Fand ich auch so ähnlich.
Das ist ein schönes Lebensmotto.
Warte mal, ich poste mal die...
Was haben die denn da bei Davanda für eine 404-Seite?
Da.
Ist mir egal, lass ich jetzt so.
Ich lass das jetzt so.
Ich bin dann in den Laden gegangen, der ist nämlich in Kreuzberg, und dann hab ich noch ein Magnet-Dingsbums hier für den Kühlschrank bekommen. Und da steht drauf, ist mir egal, ich ess das jetzt einfach. Das klebe ich auf den Club-Kühlschrank drauf. Dann passt das nämlich perfekt.
Den Club-Kühlschrank, aber ist mir egal, ich schmeiß das jetzt weg.
Wir machen heute keine Vier-Stunden-Sendung.
Übrigens, was mir da noch eingefallen ist, hier Fail-Center, ne? Also, wo wir letztens ja, nachdem wir irgendwie unsere Nix hier gegenseitig praktizieren.
Wer hat denn am meisten Freunde jetzt?
Wer hat am meisten Freunde? Ich hab 100.
100?
100 Leute.
Ich hab ja heute fett Werbung gemacht und den Hucke mal einzogen.
Wie hast du das getwittert?
Ich bin jetzt bei 194.
Du hast getwittert?
Nein, da hab ich nicht, auch nicht Spaß. Aber jung, jetzt strengt der noch ein bisschen an.
194?
Nein, es war nur ein Spaß. Ich hab 86.
Okay, und du, Max?
Gleich klingelt's wieder in der Sendung hier, wetten.
71.
71? Ja, bin ich ja hier wohl der Chef, wa?
Und dabei spielst du gar nicht.
Oh, das ist gerade um vier hochgesprungen.
128, fett. Also wir wollen die 500 mal voll machen.
Wenn wir alle zusammenlegen.
Ja, mit den Request. Ich wiederhole nochmal. Wir haben hier Max 2, 3, was? 3, 4, 3, Max. Dann haben wir hier Hucke, H-U-K-L.
Du hast auch GSM an hier, mein Freund.
Ja, ich mach auch GSM.
Dann haben wir Bad Prit, also der böse Prit. Und dann haben wir noch Dennis, 23, 42.
Jetzt macht ihr hinne, ich will hier immer hier... Ich spiele auch nie hin. Ihr könnt euch einfach jemanden besorgen, über den ihr in jeder Top-Score-Liste überwertigt.
Ich finde das ganz charmant. Also einige Leute haben ja einfach diesen Default-Text genommen, den man da so mitschicken könnte.
Ja, man kann da auch eigene Text eintippen.
Genau, und manche haben da wirklich schöne Botschaften geschickt. Ich finde, wenn ihr schon alle vor mir in der Rangliste sein wollt, dann könnt ihr mir auch einen schönen Text schicken.
Wir nehmen natürlich nur Freunde, die uns auch gewinnen lassen.
Ich will welche, die mir ein bisschen Druck machen.
Ja, da habe ich nur so eine.
Aber ihr seid ja alle so ein bisschen hinterher bei Flight Control, finde ich.
Ich habe überhaupt gar keine Zeit, diese Spiele zu spielen.
Du hast den ganzen Tag in der Bahn gesessen? Und im Taxi noch mal eine halbe Stunde? Was hast du im Taxi gemacht?
Im Taxi habe ich Podcasts gehört.
Aber Jungs, wie viele Ping-Freunde habt ihr denn mittlerweile?
Ich habe keinen Ping.
Da gibt es keine Freunde, da gibt es nur Follower.
Opfer.
Aber bei...
Können wir nochmal betonen, dass Ping der totale Finger fail ist? Oder eigentlich meine Ping ist doch scheiße.
Aber sie haben es verbessert. Sie haben Kritikpunkte wahrgenommen. Nämlich zum Beispiel hatte ich ja bemängelt, dass man halt, wenn man in seiner Library ist und Musik hört, kann man nicht sagen, ich finde I like this music. Nein, da musste man ja erst in den Store, dann auf Ping und dann klicken. Jetzt kann man das aus seiner Library rausmachen. Zum Beispiel. Als eine Verbesserung. Und da gab es noch ein paar andere Sachen, also ein Kollege hat das ja immer an.
Prost Steve, du hast uns erhört. Dennis, du hast getwittert, das iTunes 10.01-Update fixt die Probleme mit dem Firefly-Media-Server.
Heißt?
Davor die 10.0, ich hab zu Hause halt diesen Firefly-Media-Server auf meinem FreeBSD laufen. Der tut so, als wenn er halt so ein iTunes-Dings wäre und announced sich, bonjour, dass du den mit deinem iTunes-Dings anklickst, dann kommt die ganze Musik, dass du den dann abspielen kannst, obwohl die auf dem FreeBSD sind. M-T-D-A-A-P, Multisreaded, war es auch immer die Abkürzung, wenn dahinter hieß, wirklich nicht mehr. Und mit dem 10.0 ging das nicht mehr. Da hab ich schon gelesen und im Apple-Forum war da so ein Typ, der hat gesagt, Apple will jetzt so einen Tag gesetzt haben, dass es sich irgendwie um Audio handelt. Also kein Audio oder irgendwie so. Und dann haben die das hart gekodet in diesen Source, hab ich reingehackt, neu compiled gestartet und dann ging's wieder. So und hab das aber nur im Club gemacht, aber bei mir zu Hause nicht. Und dann kam die 10.0.1 und da stand ja auch drin, dass irgendwie die Kompatibilität mit anderen Mediashares oder irgendwie so verbessert wurde. Und dann hab ich's bei mir zu Hause getestet, wo ich diesen Patch noch nicht hatte. Und siehe da, es ging dann. Das heißt, dieser Patch ist nicht mehr nötig, sondern es war ein Apple-Bug und jetzt geht wieder alles. Sonst war da eigentlich nix weiter.
Ja und ich meine mit diesem Ping da, ehrlich gesagt, mir ist das überhaupt nicht recht, dass jetzt dieses Ping sich dann auch noch wirklich in jede Zeile reinfüllen kann. Ja, ich meine noch bin ich so im Beobachtungsmodus.
Ich lass das noch an, ja.
Es gab selten etwas von Apple, was so unattraktiv war für mich, wie das. Ich weiß gar nicht, Follower. Ich guck mal, was ich für Follower hab hier.
Vor allem die größte Schweinerei, finde ich ja, dass Steve hat ja irgendwie so getan, als hätte er selber eine Seite, aber...
Hat er nicht, ne?
Hat er nicht, ne.
Er hat nur so getan, als ob...
Na es gibt natürlich wahnsinnig viele Steve Jobs da bei Ping, ja, aber das sind alles halt... Faker.
Ja, aber sein Twitter-Account ist doch echt, oder?
Ja, was, wie? Steve hat einen Twitter-Account?
Es gibt noch so ein...
Scott Forstall hat einen mit zig Millionen Followern und keinem einzigen Feed.
Stimmt, es war irgendwie, kam da raus, dass er... Wie hieß denn das?
Also ich weiß nicht, dieses Ping macht mich überhaupt nicht an.
Ach, Ping ist furchtbar. Es gab CEO Steve Jobs oder wie war der Twitter-Account von...
Habt ihr diesen großartigen...
Ah ja, CEO Steve Jobs, der ist relativ lustig.
Habt ihr diesen großartigen... Diese großartigen Blog-Artikel von diesem Blinden gelesen, der über seine Erfahrungen mit dem Mac und mit dem iPhone...
Was wollen Sie sehen?
Hammer.
Nochmal was?
Naja, ein Blinder hat darüber geblockt, dass er ein iPhone bekommen hat und so, wie das so für ihn ist. Und später dann auch, wie...
Nee, haben wir noch die Blindenbedienung, VoiceOver und so.
Naja, meint einfach, die Kurzzusammenfassung ist, das iPhone ist das Beste, was dem Blinden bisher passiert ist.
Das ist eigentlich krass, oder? Das ist so das einzige Telefon ohne Tasten für so ein...
Ja, das ist das einzige Telefon, was Blinde vollständig bedienen können. Das macht man sich gar nicht so bewusst, dass dieses VoiceOver da drin ist. Und dann hat er sich später auch eine geile Geschichte wie er da mehrfach in diesem Store da irgendwie auftaucht. Also im Apple Store. Und er irgendwie endlich seinen fucking MacBook kaufen möchte. Oder nein, iMac, Entschuldigung. Und dann so seine Erfahrungen beschreibt mit VoiceOver. Ich hab das dann auch mal, ich muss sagen, ich hab selber das auch noch nicht so gemacht. Hab mal so VoiceOver eingeschaltet auf meinem Mac und damit mal ein bisschen... Also wer überhaupt nicht weiß, wovon ich jetzt gerade rede. Also VoiceOver ist seit 10.3, 10.4 Tiger.
Keine Ahnung, ist auf jeden Fall was.
Ich glaub seit 10.3 oder 10.4. Wurde dann aber auch wirklich von Version zu Version nachhaltig verbessert. Irgendwann haben sie halt diese tolle Stimme hinzugefügt. Alex, wo er auch zu schreiben soll, dass er sich irgendwie komplett weggeworfen hätte. Beim Vorlesen zum Beispiel genau dieses Blogartikel, das der da gerade schreibt. Dass das Ding, also dass diese Stimme sogar atmet.
Die klingt recht gut.
Ich mein, es klingt immer noch wie eine computergenerierte Stimme, aber der macht halt nicht nur Pausen, sondern er macht halt auch Atempausen. Und grundsätzlich ist halt dieses VoiceOver, also es gibt etwas, was ich toll finde an VoiceOver. Also erstens, was man feststellen muss, der Mac kommt heutzutage mit Screenreader-Software kostenlos dazu. Screenreader-Software für einen Windows-Rechner kostet halt mehr als der Mac. Und ist beileibe nicht so gut. Und ist vor allem systemübergreifend. Das heißt, wenn man seine Programme halbwegs konform programmiert und zum Beispiel nicht in Flash macht, sondern ordentlich Coco benutzt, dann gewinnt man eben einen Großteil Accessibility hinzu. Man sollte es natürlich trotzdem mal testen, ob man nicht irgendwas vorbeiprogrammiert hat oder irgendwas falsch gemacht hat. Aber diese ganze Nummer, dass Blinde in der Lage sind, auch solche zweidimensionalen, grafisch orientierten User-Interfaces zu benutzen, eben weil das Betriebssystem diese Oberfläche vorsieht, das ist schon mal was wert. Beim iPhone ist es halt so, dass man im Prinzip noch mal auf so eine Metaebene kommt. Und was normalerweise ein Touch ist, der was auswählt, ist dann erstmal eine Selektion. Und das musst du dann halt noch mal bestätigen.
Aber es ist halt auch nur für, wie der Chat auch gerade schon richtig angemerkt hat, für den englischsprachigen Raum. Also Alex was Deutsches vorlesen lassen, kannst du da komplett knicken und Open My Browser und Konsorten kannst du halt auch nicht in Deutsch sagen. Und das wird sich wahrscheinlich auch auf lange Sicht nicht ändern, deswegen ist das dann auch nur für die englischsprachigen Blinden.
Es geht da nicht so sehr um Spracherkennung, sondern wirklich nur ums Aussprechen.
Ja, aber du musst halt trotzdem ja bestimmte Sachen...
Man kann... Also jetzt bin ich ein bisschen wackelig, aber ich meine es gibt zumindest deutsche Stimmen zu kaufen.
Für Mac?
Ja.
Ich bin mir jetzt gerade nicht ganz sicher, an was ich mich da erinnere, ob das früher noch Mac OS war, oder ob das jetzt auch für Mac OS X gilt. Aber ich glaube, das gilt für Mac OS X.
Also ich hatte mal...
Entschuldigung, ob das dann schon alles ist, was man braucht, weiß ich auch nicht. Aber grundsätzlich funktioniert Voice Over, also das Vorlesen schon, aber du hast recht, nicht unbedingt auf Deutsch. Also das fände ich auch mal super interessant. Ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das blinde zu hören, wenn dem so ist. Wenn wir blinde Mac-User haben, davon würde ich gerne mal mehr erfahren. Schreibt uns. Genau. Das würden wir hier ganz gerne mal mit einbauen und vielleicht auch mal jemanden dazuschalten hier per Telefon oder so. Darüber würde ich gerne mal berichten. So, was haben wir noch? iTunes wird immer dicker. Das 10.1, was jetzt irgendwie demnächst kommt.
Und es ist immer noch kein 64-Bit und kein Cocoa.
Das hatten wir ja schon.
Das hatten wir schon. Und jetzt kommt da noch ein Printserver dazu, unter Windows.
Stimmt, den haben sie ja auch noch mal drin.
Ich frage mich, was da noch dazu kommt. Irgendwie noch einen Barcode-Scanner. Das geht gar nicht, oder?
Das iTunes-Betriebssystem.
Also, iTunes ist wirklich ein Betriebssystem. Ich denke, dass Windows auch ein großer Grund ist, warum sie das auch auf dem Mac so richtig nicht nach vorne bringen können, weil sie halt einfach da...
Sie haben auch Safari unter Windows.
Ja, aber es ist halt...
Safari muss da nicht so viel tun, wie iTunes tut. iTunes muss da mit Geräten sprechen und mit dem Netzwerk.
Sollen sie vernünftig aufsplitten? Was mir jetzt aufgefallen ist, dass ich in einem Print-Server unter Windows... Wie heißt dieses Print-Verfahren, das wir da jetzt eingebaut haben?
E-Print.
Also E-Print heißt das von HP und sie labeln das Air-Print.
Ich hab mich jetzt noch nicht näher mit beschäftigt, aber es gibt, wenn man das SDK installiert hat, über das ich jetzt eigentlich nicht erzählen darf, da gab es einen Printer-Simulator und der scheint einen Web-Server zu starten. Also da sieht man auf jeden Fall Requests drin landen, die sehr nach HTTP-Requests aussehen. Ich glaube nämlich, dieses E-Print oder Air-Print ist nichts weiter als ein HTTP-Post von PDF-Dateien und von JPEGs.
Da würde ich sofort unterschreiben, dass es genau das ist.
Also es ist total simpel. Das ist wahrscheinlich mit ein bisschen Aufwand kann man sich so einen Apples und so einen Printer total easy fertig machen. Da könnte man darüber nachdenken, dass man dafür schicke Applikationen mit entwickeln kann. Das sind schon tolle Sachen, was weit über das Drucken hinausgeht.
Drucken wird einfach.
Ich bin skeptisch. So oft wie die Industrie schon versprochen hat.
Na gut, ich meine, PDF hat aber bewiesen, dass es über Rechnergrenzen hinweg Layout eins zu eins übertragen kann.
Ja, das schon, aber irgendwie dieses ohne Druckertreiber einfach den Knopf drücken und es kommt raus und es funktioniert und kein Setup-Hasel, keine komischen Probleme. Wir wissen schon, Drucker nicht finden, obwohl er da ist. Drucker druckt nicht. Diese IBM-Werbung, wenn irgendjemand nochmal diesen IBM-Werbespot mit ist, druckt nicht, den hätte ich auch gerne nochmal. Ja, weil irgendwie, also ich weiß nicht.
Aber es hat bisher auch noch niemand versucht, das Problem zu lösen, oder?
Na klar, doch. Irgendwie, es gibt da hier sogar Bonjour-Printer und so weiter und das funktioniert nicht ordentlich.
Es funktioniert, sobald du den Treiber drauf hast, dann erkennt er den Drucker automatisch. Aber es hat niemand so richtig probiert, dieses Drucken mal.
Also ich bin gespannt, ob es HP jetzt mit diesem E-Print löst und Apple, die damit ausspringen. Aber ich glaube nicht so richtig dran.
Also ich meine, einen JPEG irgendwo auf eine URL zu posten, das klingt einfach genug.
Das wäre schön, das wäre auch dafür.
Und, ähm, aber...
Wie gesagt, gibt halt...
Was ist denn eigentlich dieses...
Also wenn du dir halt... Du kannst mal Google nach HP und E-Print, also es gibt noch keinen Artikel in der Wikipedia zu dieser Wundertechnologie. Und auf der HP-Seite gibt's halt in irgendeiner Unterseite so ein bisschen Marketing, blablabla, was jetzt dieses E-Print ist. Und da wird dir beim Durchlesen schon, ich weiß nicht, klang, also so...
Klingt nicht, klingt nur so mittelgut?
Nee, klingt halt so wie große Töne und dann...
Ist doch auch für die Internet-Ausdrucker.
Ist selten. Und wenn ich was drucken will, dann ist es meistens immer ein Fail. Und meistens hat es was mit HP-Geräten zu tun.
Den letzten Drucker, den ich besessen hab, den konnte man an einen 64er anschließen.
Also ich druck täglich.
Internet-Ausdrucker.
Nee, das sind einfach Sachen, die muss man einfach drucken.
Wie ist denn eigentlich dieses Google Cloud Print? Das ist doch offensichtlich auch über HTTP.
Was?
Na ja, Google macht ja was... Die meinen halt das Gleiche quasi jetzt. Die haben das selbe Problem wie Apple und wollen es offensichtlich auf eine ähnliche Art killen. Die haben für ihr Chrome OS, wollen die halt auch irgendwann mal drucken und wollen halt auch nicht gigabyteweise Treiber mit sich rumschleppen. Und dafür haben sie dieses Google Cloud Print gemacht. Und da gibt es hier offensichtlich, ich guck das mir gerade mal an, da gibt es offensichtlich auch so ein paar HTTP-Rest-Anfragen, die man da stellt. Und da steht auch irgendwas von cloudprint.pdf. Also scheinen auch PDFs zu sein. Schick mal die über L.
Ist was mit dem Drucker?
Könnt ihr drucken?
Es liegt nicht am Drucker.
Es liegt am Rechner.
Denn Niemeyer hat sich im Internet ein Virus eingefangen.
Das war diese IBM-Berbung, es druckt nicht.
Das war das Beste, was IBM jemals gemacht hat, oder?
Also nicht nur im Werbungbereich.
Doch, die Werbung fand ich gut, ja. Sie haben es zwar auch nicht gelöst, aber... Aber das war auch Niemeyer mit dem Virus. Ich glaube, die wollten nur gegen Viren kämpfen.
So Leute, wir gehen die Themen aus und ich werde müde.
Du warst da, hab ich mir sagen lassen?
Ich war nicht auf der Konferenz, ich war nur auf der Party.
Ich war auch nur auf der Party, aber auf der anderen. Du warst am Sonntag da, ich war am Sonntag da.
Auf Sonntag gab es noch eine Party?
Es gab drei Partys.
Es gab drei Partys?
Ja, aber es gibt eine Gemeinde, die ist auch...
Ja, die soll wohl...
Und die ging bis in die frühen Morgenstunden, hab ich mir sagen lassen.
Ja, aber es war irgendwann so gegen 5 Uhr oder so was. Da ich mich mit... Ich weiß, dass Google den Cloud-Print-Service schon ein bisschen länger hat, aber trotzdem ist er mal spannend.
Wurdest du hier in Game Center gedisst oder was?
Wolken, Druckungsheim sag ich nur.
Ich dachte, wir könnten noch ein bisschen erzählen, aber ich war ja auch noch auf der Party und hab ein paar Freibier getrunken.
Also ich bau langsam ab hier.
Na gut.
Ah, ich hab noch ein Thema, fehlt mir gerade ein. Jetzt kommt's.
Okay, hab ich geschrieben, das Schöne bei MobileMix ist, dass wenn sie sagt, dass sie fertig sind, dass es da noch eine Dreiviertelstunde gibt.
Das geht richtig los, ja. One More Thing ist bei uns ein...
One More Things.
Facebook-Phone hab ich mir noch aufgeschrieben.
Tim und Max in den Ring.
Was? Die Frage ist ja überhaupt erstmal, was steckt dahinter?
Es ist endlich mal ein Telefon, wo man nicht mehr sagen muss, wen man anrufen will, sondern das für einen sagt so, du willst jetzt den und den anrufen. Ich hab das aus deinem persönlichen Stream rausgelesen. Keine Ahnung.
Max liked, that Tim called...
Genau, dann kann man endlich SMS liken. PC-Load-Letter.
Ja, das ist natürlich der schönste Film zu dem Thema.
Office Space.
Also hier nochmal meine Theorie zum Thema Facebook-Phone. Also ich hab keine Ahnung, was da jetzt wirklich dahinter steckt, aber als ich das so gehört habe, dass da gerüchtet wird, dass Facebook irgendwie an Phone arbeitet, dann vermute ich schlicht, dass Facebook mit irgendwelchen Herstellern, die wahrscheinlich nicht Google sind. Die nicht Google sind? Vielleicht, ja. Kann man sich durchaus vorstellen. Kann man aber auch vorstellen, dass es irgendeine von diesen Taiwan-Buden ist. Kann man auch vorstellen, dass es irgendwie Microsoft ist, die alles möglich versuchen. Was ich mir vorstellen könnte, ist, dass Facebook schlicht versucht, so Feature-Phone-Herstellern so eine Art Single-Sign-On und alles ist fertig zu verkaufen. Dass du quasi eine Software auf deinem Feature-Phone laufen lässt, wo du dann dich mit deinem Facebook-Account einloggst und dann singt er einfach wunderbar dein Adressbuch, alle Telefonnummern, tralala. Du hast irgendwie deine Applikationen webbasiert, die sozusagen deinen Facebook-Stream abbildet, wo du so ein minimalistisches Mobil-Interface hast, einfach so wie es eben auf dem iPhone auch hast. Zum Beispiel, das ist vergleichbar ähnlich, aber vor allem diese ganze Synking-Geschichte mit dem Du bist mein Adressbuch. Ich glaube, dass sie ein sehr großes Interesse daran haben, das zu machen. Und ich glaube auch, dass das durchaus Appeal hat für so Hersteller, die eh keine Eier in der Hose haben und nicht in der Lage sind, irgendwie sich die notwendige Technologie selber zu hacken, sowas dann einfach mal zu nehmen. Zumal es ja auch, naja, ich meine, bei der Popularität von Facebook für viele Leute, die in so einen Laden reinrennen, weißt du, dann so, ja, wir haben ja irgendwie Telefon A, wir haben Telefon B und da ist auch Facebook drin. Ach ja, das ist ja schöner, nehm ich doch das.
Zumal ja die Facebook, also ich bin ja Facebook-Verweigerer. Ich hab nur so einen Stalker-Account.
Ich hab nicht mal dit.
Nicht mal dit. Ich hab ja hier aber trotzdem mal bei jemanden, der so total Facebook-User ist, mal gesagt, hier hast du nicht die Facebook-App fürs iPhone und die ist ja auch total schlecht, hab ich mir sagen lassen. Die hat auch im App-Store irgendwie nur zwei Sterne oder so und alle... Aber ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass du denkst, wow, das Facebook-Universum jetzt mit touchy-Fingertipps direkt an dir dran?
Ja, mich haut dieses Facebook-Universum nicht so um. Deswegen bin ich jetzt auch von dieser App jetzt nicht so mehr da.
Also was ist das Facebook?
Du hast halt keine Freunde.
Was ist die Facebook?
Doch, mehr als wir.
Ich hab mehr freundschaftliche Quests als Freunde.
Arme Sau.
Ja, weil ich mag dieses bidirektionale Freundschaftsding generell nicht in Social Networks. Deswegen mag ich auch Fedda.
Bidirektional, du willst nur die bei dir aufnehmen, aber die sollen dich nicht aufnehmen oder andersrum.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich damit umgehen soll, wenn mir irgendwie 500 Leute schreiben, dass sie jetzt meine Freunde sein wollen und ich kenn die gar nicht.
Das ist furchtbar. Ja, das ist auch ein blöder Satz hier in diesem Game Center. Da sollte er stehen, ich mach dich fertig oder...
Das Game Center ist was anderes, da muss man ja nicht... Das ist ja irgendwie was anderes. Da geht es einfach so mit... Das ist einfach so digitaler Schwanzlängenvergleich für Spiele. Da weiß ich eh, dass ich dann am letzten Platz bin. Da fühle ich mich dann auch irgendwie wohl. Aber bei diesem Facebook, ich weiß immer nicht... Das geht mir auch bei allen anderen Sachen so, auch auf Xing oder so. Hallo Tim, vielleicht kannst du mich mal adden? Was soll ich davon halten?
Bei Xing hab ich da total nette Anfrage bekommen.
Ihr seid doch jung, irgendwie. Könnt ihr mir das mal erklären? Pass auf, was ich meine ist, ich war da nie drin. Es mag einfach sein, dass Leute anders umgehen mit diesem Ding. Für mich, ich hab da jetzt auch mal einfach diese Deutschsperre drin, dass das Wort Freund einfach nicht die richtige Übersetzung von Friend ist. Weil es müsste wahrscheinlich Bekanntschaft heißen oder so, aber selbst dann wäre das für mich nicht genug, weil Bekanntschaft im Netz, das funktioniert gar nicht. Das mag bei anderen halt anders sein. Weißt du, wenn man mit diesem Social Network groß geworden ist, dann edelt man halt einfach. Aber was macht man dann damit?
Das ist tatsächlich ein Problem, das hab ich ja auch so ein bisschen. Da kommt eine Freundschaftsanfrage, man kennt die Person nicht, und das macht natürlich auch total sinnlos. Dann sieht man automatisch die Neuigkeiten von der Person, die ich nicht kenne.
Aber du hast ja auch Tausende von Followers.
Aber deren Zeug lese ich nicht. Die lesen dein Zeug aber.
Das ist ja auch teilweise personal oder nicht. Ich geh grad mal aufs Klo.
Aber wenn sie es interessiert, dann interessiert sie sie halt. Dann sollen sie mich nicht bestätigen. Es muss nicht auf Gegenseitigkeit basieren.
Ist das bei Facebook auf Gegenseitigkeit?
Ja, Freunde halt.
Bei Twitter gibt es ja auch schon Leute, die dann so einen Raum haben, warum followst du mich nicht. Aber es ist extrem wenig.
Dann hat man so einen Block-Button und da kommt man drauf.
Weil die davon ausgehen, dass jeder jedem followt.
Genau, aber das waren die, die es nicht verstanden haben. Aber bei Facebook ist es halt wirklich so, da ist so dieser Zugzwang irgendwie, sich gegenseitig mal zu adden und so. Da gibt es ja auch so ein wunderschönes Hauspark-Folgen.
Zero Friends, das ist die ganze Wahrheit. Alles, was man bei Facebook wissen muss, steckt in dieser South-Part.
Letztes Jahr war ich, glaube ich, auf Twitter auf irgendeiner Liste ganz oben, weil mein Ratio zwischen Leuten, denen ich folge und Leuten, die mir folgen, so extrem hoch war, dass ich irgendwie einen ersten oder zweiten Platz hatte. Ich hatte irgendwie 20 Leute, die ich folge, aber 2000, die mir folgen, was dann sozusagen eins zu hundert war.
Ach, ich glaube, Niggy toppt das lässig.
Conan O'Brien toppt das locker. Der folgt halt einem Mädel und hat selber eine Million Follower. Also da gibt es genau auch Extrem-Beispieler wahrscheinlich.
Ich habe ja auch Deutschland gesagt.
Aber um nochmal auf Facebook zurückzukommen, was an dem Facebook-App der totale Hammer ist, ist, dass man das Adressbuch synchronisieren kann, das eingebaute mit dem Facebook-Adressbuch.
Ja, wenn man darauf steht, sein Adressbuch irgendwelchen Drittanbietern in die Hand zu drücken.
Nein, es geht ja um den umgekehrten Weg, weil man möchte, dass die Adressdaten aktualisiert werden aus Facebook heraus.
Vor allem, wenn man darauf steht, dass die Bilder aktualisiert werden.
Na wieso? Deine Telefonnummer steckt ja auch mit drin, wenn du die mir irgendwann mal gegeben hast. Aber das ist tatsächlich eine sehr praktische Funktion. Und insofern dieses, was du gesagt hast, dieses irgendwelche Feature-Phones, die dann Adressbuch-Sync mit Facebook machen, Zeit wird's, weil es ist eigentlich eher unerträglich, dass man wirklich nach wie vor Telefone hat, die ihre Adressbücher nicht synchronisieren können und ihre SMS nicht synchronisieren können. Dass wenn man ein neues Telefon sich holt, dass man dann tatsächlich gezwungen ist, alle Adressen per Hand zu übertragen, oder wie auch immer die Leute das machen. Ich glaube, die machen das wirklich per Hand. Aber aus Facebooks Perspektiven schon.
Aber ich mein, Facebook ist ja, so wie ich das verstanden hab, am Ende auch nur so was wie Twitter, nur mit... Ja, aber die machen doch da auch ihre Timelines und du schreibst dir gegenseitig auf irgendwelche Wände und so.
Facebook ist wie Twitter, bloß publizierter.
Bei Twitter lädst du keine Filme und Videos in deinen Account hoch.
Aber ich hab auch schon echt Events verpasst, weil die Leute, die dann nur auf Facebook sind, gar nicht mehr andere Sachen benutzen und auch irgendwelchen Kumpels nicht mehr Bescheid sagen, wenn sie eine Party machen, sondern die posten das auf Facebook und gehen davon aus, dass schon jeder lesen wird. Ja, ich bin auch raus, aber ich hab keinen Bock.
Ich verweige mich da.
Ich war zum Beispiel heute zu einer Lesung um acht eingeladen. Dann bin ich jetzt offensichtlich nicht.
Mach das doch nach Pigenmenschen-Kinder.
War doch auf Game Center.
Ich finde ja, dass dieses Echo-Echo mal irgendwie noch Messages mit dazu machen soll. Dann wäre das irgendwie cool, aber so.
Aber Echo-Echo will mir Dennis auch die ganze Zeit aufs Auge drücken.
Echo-Echo ist so ein Service, wenn du Echo-Echo auch installiert hast und da gemeldet bist mit deiner Nummer, dann kann ich dir meine Position schicken. Du kannst meine Position aber erst sehen, wenn du mir auch deine Position schickst, also Geolocation.
Wovon reden wir jetzt von einem Webdienst?
Von einem iPhone-App.
Echo-Echo.
Und was hab ich davon, wenn ich deine Position erfahre?
Das ist doch eh immer der Klop-Dick. Du bist gerade in Town und klickst sozusagen an und zeigst mir, wo du gerade bist, zum Beispiel in einem Hotel oder wo du auch immer gerade rumhängst und dann seh ich, oh, Max ist in Town, ich schick ihm meine Position zurück, mal gucken, wie nah wir uns sind und dann kann man ja mal Kaffee trinken.
Aber das funktioniert ja nicht. Aber das funktioniert ja nicht.
Arbeitet der auch im Hintergrund?
Ja, Background-Notification.
Und sagt der dann einem, hey, du bist gerade in der Nähe von so und so, sag dir nochmal was.
Ich schick dir jetzt einen Echo-Echo, ja? Und hab ich überhaupt deine Nummer und den ganzen Shit?
Pass mal auf.
Wie heißt du, Max? Hab ich hier, klick ich, drück ich, kriegst du.
Ich muss ja erstmal einrichten tun.
Ich kann es erst mal in der West-Germany. Kann sein. Weiß ich nicht.
Okay, Echo-Echo ist das aktuelle, wir probieren das mal aus, Spiel.
Also zum Beispiel, als ich hier, wir haben sich übrigens Leute beschwert, dass ich so wenig an euren Podcasts teilnehmen würde, ich war im Urlaub, Mann. Also jedenfalls, als ich hier durch den Schwarzwald gebrettet bin, hab ich immer meine aktuelle Position an so ein paar Kumpels und Kumpelinnen irgendwie verschickt, wo ich gerade bin. Damit die mal sehen konnten, wo ich gerade rumdüse.
Das kann man auch per Latitude machen oder so was.
Das ist kostenlos, weil es geht ja nicht über SMS, sondern halt über Background-Notification. Die werden dann angepinkt und können sehen, wo ich mich gerade am Ende der Welt aufhalte.
Aber das kann man doch auch per Latitude machen, da braucht man die Position rausschmeißen. Ja, installierst du ja halt.
Ich hab aber Echo-Echo, Mann.
Es gibt aber keine Latitude.
Wahrscheinlich benutzt Echo-Echo so.
Also keine offizielle, aber es gibt eine, die die Position einfach im Hintergrund vermittelt.
Du siehst jetzt meine Position nur, wenn du mir auch deine Position schickst. Das find ich als ganz gutes Secret-Feature. Das heißt, man kann nicht einfach mitlesen, wo einer ist, sondern muss schon auch schön selber rausrücken, wo man ist.
Ich hab noch keine SMS von denen bekommen.
Na dann dauert's ne Weile. Hokel hat's ja auch schon, aber Hokel will ja immer nicht. Hokel findet's doof.
Ich bin ein Gegner.
Soll ich dir auch mal schicken, Timme? Ich schick dir auch mal so ein Ding hier. Chaka. Der hat gar nicht gefragt, welche Nummer.
Wovon meine iPhone-benutzenden Freunde schwärmen, die nicht so online-affin sind und keinen Twitter-Account haben, das ist WhatsApp. Das ist so ein App. Das ist auf Telefonnummern-Basis. So kannst du Nachrichten an andere Leute senden. Und SMS und MMS und so ein Scheißdreck. Und kostet halt nisch.
So wie Echo-Echo, nur nicht mit Location, sondern mit Text. Auch sozusagen am Bezahlprovider wie Telekom, oh tun so dran vorbei. Ich sag ja, dieses Bezahlding ist vorbei. Daten only kommt jetzt.
Stimmt, es gibt ja richtig viele Google-Lattitude-Apps mittlerweile. Viele?
Vielleicht auch mal eine, die auf dem Tauch...
Auf den ersten Blick sehe ich so drei oder so.
Also ich hab hier, warte mal, ich guck mal kurz, von denen ich mal getestet habe.
Das ist nicht wirklich Google-Lattitude, das weiß ich jetzt gar nicht. Aber jetzt bleib mal bei deinem WhatsApp.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das auch für andere Phones existiert.
Was meinst du hier, WhatsApp mit diesem RSS-Logo da oder was?
Hat das ein RSS-Logo? Nee, das hat so ein bisschen SMS-Logo eher.
SMS-Logo, ah, WhatsApp Messenger.
Und der kostet halt...
Mit dem Telefon...
Ja genau, so ein Telefon da im Kreis. Der kostet auch Geld, dann kostet er irgendwie eine kleine Summe. Ja, ja genau, das Ding.
79 Cent. Ich denke auch, wir haben Sticke oder was.
Elko, Elko ist für umsonst.
Das stimmt.
Für umme. Aber hier sagt auch gerade den Mann, Texty ist besser als WhatsApp. Wahrscheinlich ist er der Entwickler von Texty.
Aber, also...
Den müssen wir austauschen, der ist nicht gut, oder?
Also für Kanon singen finde ich es gut. Also der Anfang war gut, finde ich.
Vielleicht kriegen wir noch ein gutes Ende hin.
Oh krass, dieses Lettich-Shut ist doch gerade aktualisiert worden. Scheint ganz gut zu sein. Also das war nämlich immer so mittelgut. Und jetzt haben wir es aktualisiert, dass man auch die Zeitabstände ein bisschen erhöhen kann, dass man nicht so viel Akku braucht und so einen Scheißdreck.
Aber ich finde das gut. So mit dem Hall kann man einfach direkt an die Stiefel.
Läuft das im Hintergrund oder so?
Wozu das denn?
Ansonsten kann er deine Position ja nicht aktualisieren.
Echo sendet nur, wenn man sagt, dass es...
Ja, und das ist Scheiße.
So ein bisschen wie?
Haben wir hier gerade Cross Talk?
Ihr redet ja, ihr redet ja, ihr redet ja. Ihr seid ja beim Thema. Deswegen unterbreche ich euch jetzt mal nicht.
Wir sind fertig. Du kannst jetzt wieder weiter unterbrechen.
Ich hab das mit diesem WhatsApp noch nicht so richtig verstanden.
Ich dachte, du bist müde.
Deswegen hab ich es ja nicht verstanden.
Es ist ein total simples... Du kannst einfach Leuten, die auch einen WhatsApp-Account haben, also die sich das App auch geholt haben, kannst du einfach deine aktuelle Position... kannst du Nachrichten schicken. Und die kriegen ja per Push-Notifikation.
Ich bin der Freund von der guten alten Postkarte.
Achso, ist das sozusagen einfach kostenlose SMS über Push?
Und damit kannst du dann noch irgendwie Sprachnachrichten und Fotos und so einen Scheiß verschicken.
Und du meinst, das ist toll?
Ich weiß nicht, also ich weiß nur, dass das ein Haufen Leute, die ich so kenne.
Und wie weißt du, wenn du mir was geschickt hast, dass mich das auch erreicht hat?
Da kommt ein Postbuzzle vorbei und bringt einen Bestätigungsnachricht. Ich weiß nicht, ob man das...
Hast du eine Rückmeldung, ob das mir auch zugestellt wurde oder nicht?
Wir können es doch einfach mal angucken.
Angucken? In einem Audiopodcast?
Wir können es ja einfach mal audiovideol testen. Podcast?
Also erstens so viel Wodka, kann ich hier gar nicht hinstellen.
Du musst dir eine andere Taste bei dem Lachen, der Hall ist...
Ich hab ja gesagt, ich bin müde.
So, ich mach jetzt hier Video für meine Enkel.
Man kann uns auch beide gleichzeitig drücken. Entweder oder, du kannst auch...
So sieht es ja aus bei Tim im Studio.
Was machst du denn jetzt hier?
Was?
Ist ja wahnsinnig.
Ist alles inoffiziell hier, alles geheim.
Das bin ich.
Mobile Max Auto-Tune geht mir auf den Sack, steht da.
Genau, los, wir gehen einfach mal alle ins Bild hier.
Ich bin noch einmal rumgefahren, alle ins Bild und wo bin ich?
Ja, hast du keinen Stativ mit?
Ja, so sieht es bei Tim aus. Der hat den ganzen Schreibtisch für sich alleine.
Streamst du das jetzt live ins Internet?
Nein, Mann.
Aber Facetime?
Ich habe jetzt hier so, was ich habe, ist so 360, das ist so eine Panoramasoftware. Ich sehe mir nicht kaputt aus. Guck mal, das geht so auf dem iPhone ganz gut. Da kann man nämlich einfach mal so...
Ich habe es nicht gepostet, könnt ihr voll vergessen.
Jetzt müssen wir erst mal diese ganzen Ups notieren. Wieso geht eigentlich meine Wireless-Testatur nicht mehr?
Deine Wireless-Maus meint sie.
Irgendwie hat mein Bluetooth hier gerade irgendwie...
Sind wir mit der Sendung jetzt fertig?
Nein, weil wir haben ja hier die ganze Zeit reden wir ja von Ups. Und ich muss mir das jetzt mal notieren.
Wir machen jetzt noch die Section My Favorite iPhone.
Standort kann man übrigens auch per WhatsApp senden. Hat mir gerade jemand getwittert.
Was war jetzt diese letzte Up, die du noch nach Watt ab?
360.
360?
Das ist so eine Panorama, das ist oft, wenn man schwenkt einfach mal so die Kamera rum. Aber ist leider nicht so richtig gut.
Und dann macht die aus einem Video einen Panorama?
Und dann macht die daraus ein Panorama.
Hat natürlich nicht die selbe Auflösung wie Foto-Panorama. Einfach nur 360?
Ja genau, einfach nur 360.
Da hab ich ja auch noch einen Tipp.
Vielleicht, also ich bin nicht so wirklich überzeugt. Also die Idee ist großartig, aber...
360... Einfach so in Zahlen 360? Ich finde da erstmal wieder ganz viel Musik. Das ist alles ein Dreck hier. 360 live, Panoramik, Panoramatik.
Warte mal, also das Icon auf dem Desktop?
360 Panorama, hier gibt es ganz viel. Tweet 360, da kannst du wahrscheinlich auch einen 3D-Twitter haben.
Ein Rundum-Tweet.
Das sind ja mehr Grad als Zeichen. Das ist so ein... Ja, so eine aufgeschnittene Weltkugel, oder ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie man das nennen sollte.
Mit den Bäumen da drin. 360 Panorama.
Genau, 360 Panorama. Also so richtig dufte ist es halt leider nicht.
Aha, so was empfiehlst du hier? Das fällt auch alles wieder auf den Podcast zurück, mein Freund.
Genau, und alle sagen dann wieder, oh, in Zukunft höre ich wieder keinen Mobile Max mehr.
Genau, guck dir mal die ab an, die sind mir in diesem Penner-Podcast empfohlen worden.
In welchem Penner-Podcast?
360 Panorama. Ich benutze ein anderes Tool für Panoramen. Damit bin ich übrigens auch...
Auch unzufrieden.
Aber bevor ich es dir sagen kann, wie es heißt, muss ich mal meinen Sync abbrechen. Wieso synkt denn das hier überhaupt das Teil?
Dann beschwerst du dich, dass es nicht synkt, jetzt beschwerst du dich, dass es nicht...
Ja, aber der synkt jetzt immer ganz viel Musik da drauf.
Ich hab überhaupt nichts geändert.
Aber echt, da weißt du nie, was er will. Nee, kann auch nur so schmal entscheiden.
Die helfen uns jetzt auch nicht.
Ja, ich weiß, bei diesen V-Modes, wir müssen vorher schon wissen, was auf welcher Taste es ist. Eigentlich wollte ich jetzt diese Schlussrede nochmal.
Naja, so pünktlich, was der Das heißt, jeder von uns hier hat andere Dinge auf seiner Taste oder was?
Nein, wir haben alle das gleiche drauf.
Also nach oben ist Developers, nicht drücken.
Aber da war vorhin noch hier...
Na, toll.
Also, das Panorama-Tool, was ich benutze, heißt Auto-Stitch.
Und macht man da mehrere Fotos nacheinander?
Genau, dann machst du mehrere Fotos nacheinander und dann legst du die einfach so in deinem normalen Album ab. Also machst einfach mal die Fotos ohne diese Anwendung. Und dann kannst du, statt du das Programm und dann wählst du einfach quasi im Uhrzeigersinn aus die Fotos in der Reihenfolge, wie du sie geschossen hast. So liegen sie ja normalerweise, das heißt du touchst da einfach nur auf eins neben dem anderen. Dann sind die da unten, dann rechnet ihr das gleich zusammen. Und das Ergebnis ist ganz passabel, dann kannst du das noch croppen, damit du eben nicht diese jaggy lines drumherum hast. Und dann kannst du das wiederum als neues Bild abspeichern.
Aber das coolere Prinzip, und das hatte schon meine Casio Exelim Digitalkamera, also meine erste Digitalkamera, so eine kleine Kompakt von Casio, die hatte schon damals so ein Panorama-Feature, das fand ich eigentlich ganz pfiffig. Da machst du ein Foto im Panorama-Modus und dann macht er dir das so halbtransparent, schiebt er dir das in ein Bild ran und dann kannst du genau den Overlap... Wo es optimal wäre, weiter zu fotografieren. Genau, und so eine Abgibt's nicht fürs iPhone, oder? Also das, was Max gerade gezeigt hat, da war es ja so richtig...
Würde ich nicht ausschließen.
Na ja, wie heißt sowas? Was will ich haben?
Zumindest geht das ja jetzt, den letzten Änderungen im... Oder den vorletzten Änderungen sogar im Api. Keine Ahnung, ich hab da länger schon nicht geguckt.
Weil so Einzelphotos... Also das, was Max gerade gezeigt hat, das sah gerade ganz cool aus, so Continuous aufzeichnen. Aber wenn du Einzelbilder machst mit diesem Overlap, dann hast du halt natürlich Full Resolution auch. Und optimierst das gleich schon zum Stitchen. Wurde schon übers V-Pad gesprochen.
Ja.
Spur noch mal zu. Die hab ich heute mal abgemacht. Ja, meinen Bumper. Den hab ich heute mal abgemacht, weil ein Kollege noch mal das Phone ohne Bumper sehen wollte. Dann war da Staub drin, weil ich eine staubige Ecke gelegt hab. Und dann wollte ich es nicht mehr ranmachen, um es vorher zu reinigen, weil ich nach Tims Bumper-Scratches...
Bumper-Scratches, das ist ein sehr schönes Wort...
.verängstigt war.
Und?
Also ich hab keine, aber ich wollte jetzt nicht ungesäubert wieder ranmachen.
Ich tausch das Ding um, sobald hier der Epistore aufmacht in Berlin.
Ich hab auch keine. Noch nicht.
Gleich sollten wir Steve einfach nochmal kurz durchsagen, dass er das gleiche hier in Prenzlberg aufmachen soll. Was hilft es uns, wenn das Ganze in West-Berlin aufmacht?
Aber warte mal ganz kurz, hier sagt gerade einer... Das ist ja weiter weg als Panorama per Gyroskop, weil nämlich auch noch eine ganz wichtige Sache ist ja, dass du den Winkel hier gerade hältst und so. Und da gibt es ja jetzt auch dieses...
Na 360 machts ja per Gyroskop.
Das hat auf einem 3GS funktioniert, das ist überhaupt nicht.
Aber wenn du auch einzelne Fotos machst, dass du halt auch um deine eigenen Achse... Du sollst ja nicht so machen, so irgendwie, sondern du sollst ja den genau auf einen Punkt lassen und dann sozusagen so... Ja, ihr könnt's leider im Radio jetzt nicht sehen, aber...
Da soll sie halt um einen Punkt drehen.
Um eine Achse drehen, genau. Und das könntest du dann auch wahrscheinlich irgendwie noch total...
Der Mittelpunkt der Achse sollte im iPhone liegen. Darum geht's.
Aber was mir halt bei den ganzen Dingern fehlt, ist, dass die haben nichts, womit man sich das wirklich gut angucken kann. Also ich verzeih gerne so ein 360, so ein Panoramaprogramm, wo ich ein Panorama mitmachen kann und dann......habe ich nicht irgendwie ein dämliches Foto. Nein, kein QuickTime VR, sondern irgendwas, was im Netz ist, was ich per Twitter rumschicken kann. Wofür mache ich denn den ganzen Scheiß?
Also Pano wird hier gerade empfohlen.
Habe ich ein QuickTime VR auf meinem iPhone?
Javascript.
Ja, ja, irgendwie so irgendwas. Das wäre super.
Ich will HDR-Video.
Hatte das Apple nicht neulich auf seiner Webseite so ein Beispiel? So QuickTime VR-artiges Ding mit Javascript?
Ja, ich will halt so ein Panorama abfassen, dass das dann automatisch für mich hochladen kann. Das wäre Likaten. Das wäre Dufte.
Das wäre so schön.
Das wäre ne Wolke.
Was ist denn das hier? Guck dir das mal an.
Leute, wir haben jetzt...
Viel, viel Zeit schon wieder totgeschlagen.
Ja, es sind schon wieder fast drei Stunden um. Donnerlittchen, wa? Das muss reichen.
Ja. Also wenn wir jetzt hier im Zwei-Wochen-Rhythmus sind, dann...
Ja, wir sind im Zwei-Wochen-Rhythmus. Das haben wir jetzt schon echt gnadenlos durchgehalten.
Zum zweiten Mal.
Ja, ich hoffe, das wird auch anerkannt. Und nicht hier durch...
Gibt ja auch jedes Mal was zu essen. Ach so.
Ach so, von euch wird das jetzt auch noch anerkannt. Ja, das soll mir recht sein. Ja, es gibt immer was zu essen. Das hat auf jeden Fall schon mal geholfen.
Also nicht für die Hörer, sondern für uns zwei.
Ah, Anerkennung. Hier kommt gerade über den Chat, hier kommt Anerkennung.
Wirklich?
Schick ihm gleich den Flatterlink.
Ach so, und da fällt mir ein Dodo80, der offensichtlich ein totaler What's Up-Fan ist. Der hat noch geschrieben, dass die Bestätigung, ob jemand das gesehen hat, die andere Person in Form eines kleinen Häkchens nehmt eine Nachricht. Also in What's Up, wenn du deine bestätigt. Du wolltest wissen, wie die Bestätigung ist.
Entschuldigung, mein Hirn, mein Hirn.
Du hast ihn vielleicht aufhören, dich mit dem Konzert den Kopf gegen...
Funktioniert nicht so richtig. Huckel an Großhirn.
Läuft.
Hier geht nicht mehr viel.
Nee, wir sind durch.
Wir haben doch unsere... Wie viel flatterst noch gar nicht zusammen?
Ja, du hast gesagt, dass die Sendung nach zwei Stunden...
Wir haben heute noch gar nicht Android gebashed.
Doch, ein bisschen.
Gibt's sie noch?
Das sparen wir uns für später auf.
Aber ich dachte, das ist jetzt so die Schlusssektion immer.
Hate.
Haters gonna hate.
Haters. Android-Haters. Apple-Fanboys-Android-Haters. To all you Apple-Haters.
Ja, das war's.
Und naja, wir haben nicht so viel Wort darüber verloren, aber dieses Spielzeug hier, das wird weiterentwickelt. Vielleicht habt ihr auch noch coole Ideen. Wie wir da hier ganz tolle Sachen machen können. Ja, es muss noch mehr gehen als nur Hall, oder?
Hall finde ich schon mal supergut. Das hat auch so ein bisschen was von Tropfsteinhöhle und da kann man mal als Stiefenwort, da kann man ein Wort an Stief richten und so.
Man könnte verschiedene Hall-Situationen machen. Ich hab auch so Kellerhall und irgendwie Blümchenwiese und so.
Und vor dem goldenen Tor. Blümchenwiese? Ja.
Wie klingt denn Blümchenwiese?
Kann ich dir jetzt nicht zeigen.
Wie heißt dieser Filter eigentlich? Raucherkrebs?
Na, das läuft unter Resonator.
Der ist ja aufs gleiche.
Der ist nicht gut, nee.
Der langweilt nach einer Weile.
Wir brauchen so ein Autotuning. Wie heißt das dieser Effekt ja so?
Flanger. Wie das... Kennste, ne?
Flanger.
Ich hab jetzt grad...
Ja, oder einfach so ein Voice-Waka-Waka.
Ich geh grad noch mal eine Empfehlung für so ein...
Helium-Stimme.
Helium, das kann man aber auch anders haben.
Nächste Mal Helium-Flasche von der Flatter-Kohle. Aber da darf man glaub ich nicht so viel von konsumieren.
Leute, die Stream-Einschaltzahlen gehen zurück. Was? Das ist ein deutliches Zeichen, dass wir jetzt hier auch ein Ende machen müssen. Bevor das hier noch unter 300 absinkt oder so. Das wär ja peinlich. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Ich hoffe, wir haben euch nicht zu sehr genervt hier mit dem Soundboard. Jetzt war mal wieder was dabei. Drei Stunden should be enough for everybody, würde ich sagen. Dennis, was sind deine abschließenden Worte? Okay, so soll es sein. Also halten wir jetzt das Maul.
Up The Shut Fuck, You Must.
Bis bald, Leute.
Winke, winke.